Hey everybody, this is an awesome episode. I'm really looking forward to this. Edge computing is one of these things where when I first learned about it, I thought it was just client-side computing. I thought it was something on the browser or something on your mobile device or something like that. When you think about it, there's actually a whole gradient between that and some backend-end server, right? So imagine Netflix releases a new episode that they know it's going to be super popular, their most popular show, and everybody just starts downloading it, and that would just completely blow them up, right? They also just can't put a two-gigabyte show on everybody's phone proactively. They can't do that either, right? So there has to be an answer there.
大家好，这是一期非常棒的节目。我非常期待。边缘计算就是这样一种技术，当我第一次了解它时，我以为它只是客户端计算。我以为它是浏览器上的东西、移动设备上的东西，或者是类似的东西。如果你仔细想想，实际上在它和某个后端服务器之间存在一个完整的渐进层级，对吧？想象一下，Netflix发布了一个他们知道会非常受欢迎的新剧集，也就是他们最火的节目，然后每个人都开始下载，这会直接把他们的服务器搞崩，对吧？而且他们也没法主动把一个两GB的剧集放到每个人的手机上。他们也做不到这一点，对吧？所以必须有一个解决方案。
And edge computing is a big part of that answer. And so there's a lot of complexity around how this all works. And I'm so happy to have, you know, head of product at HarperDB, Jackson Rep here to really dive into edge computing and learn as much as we can about this topic. So thanks for coming on the show, Jackson.
边缘计算正是这个解决方案的重要组成部分。因此，这一切如何运作涉及很多复杂性。我非常高兴能请到HarperDB的产品负责人杰克逊·雷普（Jackson Rep）来到这里，和我们一起深入探讨边缘计算，并尽可能多地了解这个话题。感谢你来到节目，杰克逊。
Thank you very much for having me. I really appreciate it. Cool. So we always kind of start this off. How has COVID kind of changed Harper and changed your kind of work style? What do you feel has been the sort of big salient point from that? Well, we're a relatively young company formed in 2017.
非常感谢邀请我来。我真的很感激。太好了。所以我们通常会这样开始。COVID疫情在多大程度上改变了Harper以及你们的工作方式？你觉得其中最突出的重点是什么？嗯，我们是一家相对年轻的公司，成立于2017年。
We were in a co-working space. We had a bunch of different little isolated spaces together, and we had finally got enough traction, got our product where we thought, yeah, we took another round of funding and we leased an office space in January of 2020. Oh, wow. One month later, everybody was like, maybe that was a bad idea. And we became a fully distributed company in much the same way we are a distributed product, a distributed database. So after a few months, we took a company survey and every single person was more productive than they had been in the office. I think we all realized we had a much better work-life balance. My cats are much less lonely, although lonely was kind of their jam.
我们曾经在一个联合办公空间里。我们有很多不同的小隔间，我们终于获得了一些发展势头，产品也达到了我们预期的水平，于是我们完成了又一轮融资，并在2020年1月租下了一个办公室。哦，哇。一个月后，大家都在想：这或许是个坏主意。于是我们变成了一家完全分布式公司，这和我们的分布式产品、分布式数据库非常相似。所以在几个月后，我们做了一次公司调查，发现每一个人都比在办公室里时更有生产力。我想我们都意识到，我们拥有了更好的工作与生活平衡。我的猫没那么孤独了，尽管孤独一直是它们的最爱。
And we decided sort of as a company that the money we would have spent on rent, we think we're going to spend on annual or biannual retreats where employees can bring their families and we'll go somewhere like Mexico and do morning, you know, planning meetings and afternoon is yours. Because to be honest, we're still small enough, we can pull that off. And part two is, you know, a lot of us, at least at our company, are pretty okay with, you know, being able to better divide that line between, you know, software development is often one of those all-encompassing things that takes over your soul and all of your available hours. And I don't know
我们作为一家公司决定，原本要花在租金上的钱，我们将用来举办年度或半年度的员工胜地活动（Retreats），员工可以带家属参加，我们会去像墨西哥这样地方，上午开开规划会议，下午就是你的时间。因为说实话，我们公司规模还够小，所以能做到这一点。第二部分是，你知道，我们中的很多人，至少在我们公司，都很愿意更好地划分这条界限，因为软件开发通常是那种会吞噬你的灵魂和所有可用时间的无所不包的工作之一。我不知道
about you, but I'm not as young as I used to be and I have kids and I would like to see them. They are not terrible people. I agreed with you up until the end. No, just kidding. But no, I think you're totally right. I think, you know, having, you know, a get together at some cadence, maybe, you know, every year or every, you know, semi annually or something like that, you know, that is super nice. And that can, that can, you know, keep that bond going and like start that bond up with new folks. But coming into the office every day, I mean, you know, Patrick and I used to have huge commutes, like hour each way commutes. And that just eats so much of your day. And so many times, you know, you're there. And there were days where I went in and left and didn't even really talk to anybody. It's kind of
你怎么样，但我已经不再年轻了，我有孩子，我想见见他们。他们并不是可怕的人。直到最后我都同意你的看法。不，开个玩笑。不过说真的，我觉得你完全说对了。我觉得，以某种节奏聚会，比如每年一次，或者每半年一次之类的，这真的很好。这能维持这种纽带，并与新人建立这种纽带。但是每天去办公室，我是说，帕特里克（Patrick）和我以前都要忍受很长的通勤，单程要一个小时。那真的吃掉了你的一天中的大部分时间。很多时候，你在那里，有些日子我去了又走了，甚至都没怎么跟任何人说话。这就好比
like, well, what was I doing for those two hours? Right. So, yeah, I think, you know, you can get a lot done. You can get by with not coming into the office every day. I think that's that's definitely something we've all taken away. So what happened with your lease? Like, were you able to break that lease or or how does that work? In general, I'm always fascinated with what happened to corporate property at this point. I think we got out of it and I think it was because basically they had entire multiple floor tenants who were trying to fight the same battle. And to be honest, I believe probably the real estate agents lawyers were too busy fighting real battles. Not to worry about little startup who took a corner unit with almost no windows.
“我这俩小时到底在干嘛？”对吧。所以，是的，我觉得你可以完成很多工作。不每天去办公室也能过得去。这绝对是我们大家的共同体会。那么你们的办公室租赁合同怎么样了？你们能解约吗，或者这到底是怎么处理的？总的来说，我总是对企业资产在此时的遭遇感到好奇。我想我们退租了，我想这是因为基本上他们有整整好几层的租客都在为同样的事情抗争。说实话，我猜房地产经纪人的律师们当时正忙着打真正的官司，顾不上我们这样一个几乎没有窗户的角落小初创公司。
I honestly, I look at it and I say, to your point about commutes, I used to commute an hour every day. And then I moved to Harbor DB and my commute was 15 to 20 minutes. And I was like, that is so much better. And then I switched to a five second commute from my bedroom to the living room. And there is something to be said for the decompression that comes with a commute oh that's true yeah from being sitting there and staring at your code like that kid who doesn't know why it works and doesn't know why it doesn't work and all of a sudden it works again and you're like okay i'm done and you walk out in the living room and kids don't respond that way they just you cannot you cannot debug them they are just a constant challenge. And, and to be able to be
老实说，我看着这些，然后顺着你刚才关于通勤的话题说，我以前每天通勤一小时。后来我跳槽到HarperDB，通勤时间变成了15到20分钟。当时我觉得：这好太多了。然后我又换成了从卧室到客厅的五秒钟通勤。通勤带来的那种精神解压确实有其价值。哦，那倒是真的，对吧？从坐在那儿死盯着代码，就像那个不知道代码为什么能跑、也不知道为什么不能跑的小孩一样，突然间代码又行了，你就想：好吧，我搞定了。然后你走到客厅里，孩子们可不会那样回应你，你根本无法对他们进行调试，他们就是一个持续不断的挑战。
present with them after you've spent, you know, a whole day banging your head against your desk, that is a skill in and of itself, being able to walk out and be present and not be focused on work still. Yeah. Oh man, you hit on something that's such a, such a good point. I mean, so a couple of things to riff on there is when I started taking a walk, so I started walking to work where I'd basically just walk in a circle around our neighborhood and that's my walk to work. And I just feel like mentally it kind of puts me at a different place. So far, it seems to be working.
在你花了一整天把头撞在桌子上之后，能够陪伴在他们身边，这本身就是一项技能，能够走出来并专注于当下，而不是依然想着工作。哦，天哪，你触及了一个非常、非常好的点。我是说，有几件事可以顺着聊聊：当我开始散步时，我开始步行上班，基本上就是在我们社区周围绕圈走，那就是我的上班步行。我只是觉得从精神上讲，它把我带到了一个不同的地方。到目前为止，这似乎挺管用的。
Maybe it's a little bit of placebo effect there or something, but I feel like it's doing something. And then the other thing is, yeah, I feel, I feel like even at work, you know, there's, there'll be a situation that's totally on fire and you have to make some really hard decisions very quickly. And there's, it's a zero sum game and everyone's really upset. And then you go from that to, uh, let's say a, a meeting, a one-on-one meeting with somebody who's doing an amazing job. And you have to kind of switch gears from, you know, your, your, your sort of debate face to, to someone who's like extremely excited and happy and appreciative. And then that meeting ends and now you're with your family, which is like another dimension. So I feel like being able to toggle all of these
也许里面有点安慰剂效应什么的，但我感觉它确实起到了作用。然后另一件事是，是的，我觉得即使在工作中，也会遇到那种火烧眉毛的情况，你必须非常迅速地做出一些非常艰难的决定。这是一个零和博弈，每个人都很沮丧。然后你从那种状态切换到，比方说，一场与某个表现极其出色的员工的一对一会议。你必须转换思维，从那种争论的面孔，转换成面对一个极度兴奋、快乐和感激的人。然后会议结束了，现在你要和家人在一起，这就像是另一个维度。所以我觉得能够熟练切换所有这些
different persona that, that has been really, really difficult, um, over VC. Whereas, whereas, whereas in a real office, you would at least walk from one room to the other and you'd have time to sort of, you know, like reframe yourself over and over again. Yeah. Just sitting down to dinner and, you know, kind of crossing your hands and saying, all right, let's talk about your performance today. That's right. It's my understanding that you spilled food on your, on your shirt at the beginning of the day.
不同的角色面具，通过视频会议来做真的是难上加难。而在一个真正的办公室里，你至少会从一个房间走到另一个房间，你有时间不断地重新调整自己的状态。是的。只要坐下来吃晚饭，双手交叉，然后说：“好了，我们来聊聊你今天的表现吧。”没错。“据我了解，你在今天刚开始的时候就把食物洒在衬衫上了。”
And then you had to walk around with that stain. That's clearly not the image we want to project Grayson. Yeah, that's right. You might have to go live next door. Oh man. So cool. It sounds like a, yeah, it really worked out for the best. And I think that this acceleration, I mean, definitely, you know, you wouldn't ever wish COVID on anybody or any country or anything like that. But there has been some real silver lining. I think this has been one of them where we've started to understand the working relationship better. Cool. So yeah, let's dive into edge computing. So initially, I thought edge computing was just on the browser, on the mobile app, right? And that's definitely like the extreme edge. I mean, there's definitely things you want to do in that space, but there's a whole bunch of stuff in between that and let's say an EC2 instance you have running. And so kind of walk us through what that really is,
“然后你不得不带着那个污渍到处走。这显然不是我们想要展现的形象，格雷森（Grayson）。”是的，没错。你可能得搬到隔壁去住了。哦，天哪。太酷了。听起来，这真的是朝着最好的方向发展了。而且我认为这种加速——我是说，当然，你绝不会希望COVID发生在任何人、任何国家或任何类似的事情上。但确实有一些真正的积极面。我认为这就是其中之一，我们开始更好地理解工作关系。好吧，让我们深入探讨边缘计算。所以最初，我以为边缘计算只存在于浏览器上、移动应用上，对吧？这绝对是极端的边缘。我是说，确实有一些事情你想在那个领域做，但在那和我们运行的EC2实例之间，还有大量的东西。所以，给我们大致讲讲那到底是什么，
like what is available there and what can people do on the edge? Well, the edge is defined loosely, to say the least. We used to think of the edge as not so far out as the browser because there's so many limitations in terms of what you can do. You're in a sandbox. So the next smallest compute unit that we would focus on, and this is both at HarperDB and my prior company, which is an IoT platform, things like Raspberry Pis, small microcomputer, you know, Jetson boards, stuff like that, where you can run code that handles a workload and will perform some smaller tasks than could be handled on a larger server up in the cloud. What you find though, is that
那里有什么可用资源，人们可以在边缘做些什么？嗯，边缘的定义很宽泛，保守地说。我们过去认为边缘没那么遥远，没到浏览器的地步，因为在你能做的事情上有很多限制。你处在一个沙盒中。因此，我们会关注的下一个最小计算单元，无论是在HarperDB还是在我之前的公司（一家物联网平台公司）里，都是诸如树莓派、小型微型计算机、Jetson板之类东西，你可以在上面运行代码来处理工作负载，并执行比云端更大服务器上所能处理的更小任务。不过你会发现，
that hardware is not super ready for a lot of dynamic programming and workloads. If you want to be out in a vineyard, for example, an autonomous vineyard just outside of Tucson, Arizona under my previous company. And we are automatically watering the vines and using compute to analyze soil moisture content and humidity and temperature and canopy and shade and infrared and all of that stuff. And we are still using ruggedized raspberry pies out there because it's hard to find something that will give you the flexibility to install a platform or a database or whatever you might want to store or run on it and then likewise uh handle the reality that it rains outside or that it's 150 degrees sometimes when when you're down there measuring temperature so the hardware was a huge challenge and we were banging our head against that at
这种硬件并没有为大量动态编程和工作负载做好充分准备。比如，如果你想在一个葡萄园里，在我前公司位于亚利桑那州图森市外的一个自主葡萄园里。我们正在自动给葡萄藤浇水，并使用计算来分析土壤含水量、湿度、温度、树冠、阴影、红外线以及所有这些东西。我们在那里仍然使用加固型的树莓派，因为很难找到这样一种设备：它既能提供灵活性来安装平台、数据库或任何你想要存储或运行的东西，又能同时处理下雨或有时候温度高达150华氏度（约65度）测量温度时的现实情况。所以硬件是一个巨大的挑战，我们在HarperDB一直在为此头疼，
HarperEB because we knew that distributed computing would require distributed data. And we knew the benefits of distributed computing. Running an AI model at the edge on a small data set or stream data set is much more efficient than shipping it all up to the cloud, especially when you have intermittent connectivity, which is often the case out at what we call the edge. Can you describe it? So I thought that the edge was like maybe the ISP or something like, like what exactly is the edge? Is the edge like your house or, or is the edge some server in between you and the internet
因为我们知道分布式计算需要分布式数据。并且我们知道分布式计算机的好处。在边缘的小型数据集或流式数据集上运行AI模型，远比把它们全部运送到云端要高效得多，特别是当你拥有间歇性连接时，这通常是我们所说的边缘的常见情况。你能描述一下吗？所以，我以为边缘可能是ISP（互联网服务提供商）或者类似的东西，究竟什么是边缘？边缘是你的房子，还是你和互联网之间某个服务器，
or what exactly is that? The Edge is everything outside what I would call a major colo facility, like a major cloud provider. So we've partnered with Lumen, the old CenturyLink slash Level 3. They're pushing micro-edge data centers, which are still data centers and still much more server capacity than
或者那到底是什么？边缘是所有我称之为主要托管设施（比如主流云服务商）之外的东西。因此，我们与Lumen（前身是CenturyLink / Level 3）进行了合作。他们正在推动微边缘数据中心的发展，这些依然是数据中心，并且服务器容量比
I have ever had in my closet at home. But to them, that's the edge. And that was really the change for us to realize that the edge isn't a wearable because we can't be installed on it, but it is the edge to some people who can compile apps and put it on a watch. For some people, that's the edge. For a lot of people, you know, where your sensors are and where you're collecting that data is the edge. That's how you define it. So you fight the battle and you find the hardware to pick and survive there and collect that data. But for other people, the edge is simply my customers have a really fast connection. I can trust that that connection will exist. I just want to move my application closer to them so that the round trip to the API
我在家里的储藏室里见过的任何东西都要大得多。但对他们来说，这就是边缘。这才是真正让我们意识到的一点：边缘不是可穿戴设备，因为我们无法安装在上面，但对于某些能够编译应用并将其放在手表上的人来说，这就是边缘。对某些人来说，那是边缘。对许多人来说，你的传感器在哪里、你在哪里收集数据，这就是边缘。这就是你的定义方式。所以你克服困难，寻找硬件并在那里生存下来，收集这些数据。但对其他人来说，边缘很简单：我的客户拥有非常快的连接，我可以相信这种连接会存在。我只是想把我的应用离他们更近一点，以便到API的往返延迟
is a millisecond instead of 300 milliseconds. That's the sort of performance that I want to get back. So we find that lots of people are defining the edge. The people who own giant cloud data centers people are defining the edge. I mean, the people who own giant cloud data centers are definitely defining the edge as a slightly smaller data center, slightly closer to the users. And the people who are building apps that collect sensor data and make use of that with machine learning, they're pushing it out further and solving those hardware challenges. I don't think we really need to truly define it more than that because tomorrow we're
是1毫秒而不是300毫秒。这正是我想要获得的性能。所以我们发现很多人都在定义边缘。拥有巨型云数据中心的人在定义边缘。我是说，拥有巨型云数据中心的人绝对把边缘定义为稍微小一点、离用户更近一点的数据中心。而那些构建收集传感器数据并通过机器学习利用这些数据的应用的人，则在进一步推动它并解决那些硬件挑战。我觉得我们真的不需要做比这更精确的定义了，因为明天我们就会
going to invent some new technology that's inside me. Yeah, that's right. We're all the edge. Okay. Oh, that totally puts it in perspective because I did a bit of research prior to the show. People who listen to the show know I'm an AI person, so I don't have any background in full stack, but I did a bit of research and what I saw was things like Cloudflare Edge and AWS Lambda Edge. And that sounded like, as you said, just a smaller data center. And there's just a lot of them. But it sounds like Edge is much bigger than that. I mean, it's also your vineyard is a great example.
发明一些植入我体内的全新技术。是的，没错。我们所有人都是边缘。好的。哦，这确实让我转换了视角，因为我在节目开始前做了一些研究。听节目的观众都知道我是搞AI的，所以我没有任何全栈背景，但我做了一些研究，我看到的是像Cloudflare Edge和AWS Lambda Edge之类东西。听起来就像你说的，只是一个更小的数据中心。而且数量很多。但听起来边缘要宏大得多。我是说，你的葡萄园就是一个很好的例子。
So in this case, you have this swarm of raspberry pies on this vineyard, and now that's the edge. So with Harper, for example, are you concerned with all of those different types of edge computing, or are you focused more on the former or the latter? out when I first joined HarperDB, we were very, very much focused on let's go into AI-powered classifications in the mining industry. And that's a very small, it might be a Dell Edge device or a Raspberry Pi for proof of concept. And let's do our calculations and let's provide real benefit. And we could absolutely do that. But the client loves it. The result is great. And they're like, cool, we ran that, but we can't really run a raspberry pie in this hot, smelting environment. So what hardware solutions do we have? And inevitably, you run across budget concerns because if we've got 150 of those across a plant and you're going to spend now $3,000 on a ruggedized piece of hardware, well, now all of a to create a HarperDB device with our product on it,
所以在这种情况下，这个葡萄园里有一群树莓派，现在这就是边缘。那么以Harper为例，你们关注所有这些不同类型的边缘计算吗？还是说你们更多地专注于前者或后者？当我刚加入HarperDB时，我们非常非常专注于：让我们进入采矿业中的AI驱动分类。那是非常小的领域，为了概念验证，可能是一个Dell边缘设备或树莓派。让我们进行计算并提供真正的价值。我们完全可以做到这一点。但是客户很喜欢它。结果很好。他们说：“酷，我们运行了那个，但是我们真的无法在这个炎热的冶炼环境中运行树莓派。”所以我们有什么硬件解决方案呢？不可避免地，你会遇到预算问题，因为如果我们在一个工厂里有150个这样的设备，而你现在要花3000美元买一个加固的硬件，那么所有的资金都会用来创建一个带有我们产品的HarperDB设备，
and we incur that capital cost. And now they can pay monthly so they can run it as OpEx. And from a budgetary perspective, it's very, very challenging to have that be the edge. And we found that the big guys with all the money who are absolutely pushing their giant cloud service offerings to these smaller data centers, they are just as desperate to move data and compute and functionality and capability to the edge. And they have much bigger pocketbooks and they can make it happen more quickly. So, I mean, not a lot more quickly. We can do POCs all day long for smaller companies, but there's still a real hardware problem out there for true edge computing. Yeah, that makes sense. So let's step back a little bit. Now we've defined edge computing,
然后我们要承担这笔资本开支。现在他们可以按月付费，所以可以将其作为运营开支（OpEx）。从预算的角度来看，让它成为边缘是非常非常具有挑战性的。我们发现，那些拥有大量资金、绝对在向这些较小数据中心推销其巨型云服务产品的大公司，同样迫切地希望将数据、计算、功能和能力转移到边缘。他们拥有更雄厚的资金，能够更快地让它成为现实。所以，我是说，也没有快太多。我们可以一整天都为小公司做概念验证（POC），但对于真正的边缘计算来说，外面依然存在一个现实的硬件问题。是的，这说得通。那我们稍微回退一点。现在我们已经定义了边缘计算，
which I think is super, super useful to set the frame. So what got you into edge computing? Give us kind of a bit of a background on your kind of story and what led you to HarperDB. Sure. I was a partially reformed software developer. Partially reformed. Partially reformed. This is my eighth startup. I was at a communications startup where we were joining together all your phone calls, texts, emails into threads for customer service. And the UI for that, it basically, I wrote React, like literally a year before React came out. Wait, how is that possible?
我认为这对设定背景非常、非常有用。那么是什么让你进入边缘计算领域的？给我们大致讲讲你的故事背景，以及是什么引导你来到HarperDB的。当然。我是一个半路出家的软件开发人员。半路出家。半路出家。这是我的第八家初创公司。我曾在一家通信初创公司工作，我们把你们所有的电话、短信、电子邮件合并成客服的主题帖（Threads）。它的用户界面基本上是，我写了React，字面意思是，在React问世整整一年前。等等，这怎么可能？
There's like a preview release or something? No, no, I wrote effectively the functionality of these modularized HTML because there wasn't one, but I knew that that's what we needed. Wow, isn't that amazing how, how there's like a, it's literally great minds think alike. Like, you know, there's, there's, there's this idea and it just, a lot of people kind of come to the realization at the same time. Yeah. It just seemed, it seemed so obvious. And then I immediately moved, uh, well, my wife was pregnant at the time and she, she kept getting more pregnant.
好像有个预览版还是什么的？不，不，我实际上写了这些模块化 HTML 的功能，因为之前没有，但我知道这正是我们需要的。哇，这不是很奇妙吗，怎么说呢，这简直就是英雄所见略同。就像你知道的，有这样一种想法，然后很多人在同一时间想到了相同的解决方案。是的。这看起来是那么显而易见。然后我马上就……嗯，我妻子当时怀孕了，她肚子越来越大。
And I didn't want to pay cash for that baby. So I had to get a job with insurance. And I worked for DirecTV. And it was one of those jobs. I've never worked at a company where I had to wear khakis and a button down before. And it just didn't fit. So I started looking for my next opportunity. And I found an IoT platform, sort of a low-code drag and drop, drag in your sensor, block.
我可不想用现金支付那个宝宝的费用，所以我得找一份有保险的工作。我在 DirecTV 工作。那是那种我从来没去过的、必须穿卡其裤和衬衫的公司。这实在不适合我，所以我开始寻找下一个机会。我发现了一个物联网平台，有点像低代码的拖放式，把你的传感器拖进来的那种积木块。
And now the data that comes off of that, capture that from port three and divide it in two and keep a running average in your memory buffer. And if it goes above, by the way, fetch a threshold from a database, if it goes above that limit, then send an email. So it was a super easy to use platform a la Node-RED, only sort of enterprise grade. And it was a great product. costs for any given operation dropped dramatically because we didn't have to have massively powered servers on the floor and run cables to everything. These could be wireless connections. We could use low energy Bluetooth if we had the ability. So there was a tremendous opportunity for us to capture and refine data and then not send every single piece of sensorized data,
然后现在，从该设备获取的数据，从端口三捕获数据并将其除以二，在内存缓冲区中保持一个运行平均值。如果它超过了……顺便说一下，从数据库中获取一个阈值，如果它超过了那个限制，就发送一封电子邮件。所以这是一个超级容易使用的平台，类似于 Node-RED，只是有点企业级。而且它是一个很棒的产品。任何给定操作的成本都急剧下降，因为我们不需要在现场配置性能强大的服务器并为所有东西铺设电缆。这些可以是无线连接。如果有能力的话，我们可以使用低功耗蓝牙。因此，我们有巨大的机会来捕获和精简数据，而不是把每一个传感器数据……
every piece of sensor data up to the cloud. You very quickly, when you're in an installation with a thousand sensors, realize how much of your pipe you're taking up, sending everything up there to be analyzed. So it made sense from a filtering perspective to me. And then it was just about how can I make this easier, faster, more stable? What are the challenges that I have and how can I overcome them? That makes sense. And so that company that you're at, which had the IoT devices, that was from there you went to Harper. Is that the step before Harper? Correct. I was looking for a network fault tolerant data solution. And I actually, I found HarperDB just, I think may have actually searched for that. We had great SEO back then. Nice. and I integrated, I built a block for it for our platform. But I ran into some documentation issues.
把每一个传感器数据都发送到云端。当你身处一个安装了一千个传感器的现场时，你很快就会意识到，把所有东西都送到上面去分析会占用你多少带宽。所以从过滤的角度来看，这对我来说很有意义。然后接下来就是我如何能让它变得更简单、更快、更稳定？我面临的挑战是什么，我该如何克服它们？这说得通。所以你在的那家拥有物联网设备的公司，就是从那里你去了 Harper。那是去 Harper 之前的步骤吗？对的。我在寻找一个网络容错的数据解决方案。实际上我找到了 HarperDB，我猜当时可能真的搜索过。我们当时有很棒的 SEO。太棒了。我整合了它，为我们的平台编写了一个区块。但我遇到了一些文档方面的问题。
Their postman collection appeared to be a little outdated. So I rewrote that postman collection and just sent him an email at hello at harperdb.io. I'm like, hey, your documentation appears to be a little out of date. Here's a new file. I rewrote it. So that worked for me. So I could use the postman collection basically locally. I said, thanks.
他们的 Postman 集合看起来有点过时了。所以我重写了那个 Postman 集合，然后给 hello@harperdb.io 发了一封电子邮件。我说，嘿，你们的文档看起来有点过时了。这是一个新文件。我重写了它。所以这对我有用。这样我基本上可以在本地使用这个 Postman 集合了。我说，谢谢。
I continued to implement it, ran into a couple of things that I thought would be cool to have. And I wrote to them and eventually they just wrote me back and said, we would really like perhaps you to work for us. Cool. It would be cool if you could consult or just help out. I'm like, ironically, this office is about to go virtual and I have kids at home and I don't think that I can survive that. And so they invited me to office with them half time, which turned into full time.
我继续使用它，遇到了几个我认为很酷的功能。我写信给他们，最后他们回信说，我们真的很想让你为我们工作。太酷了。如果你能做顾问或者只是帮忙，那就太好了。我说，具有讽刺意味的是，这个办公室即将转为虚拟办公，我家里有孩子，我觉得我无法忍受那种环境。于是他们邀请我每周去办公室半天，后来变成了全职。
And here I am two and a half years later. That is awesome. I mean, that's I think it's a really great story. We get a lot of folks asking, how do I get into the field? Right. And I mean, there's a perfect example where they, well, I mean, they might have looked you up, but let's assume they didn't. I mean, they might not know your college degree or whether you went to this bootcamp or that bootcamp, but you're
两年半后的今天，我在这里。这太棒了。我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常棒的故事。我们有很多粉丝问，我如何进入这个领域？对吧？我的意思是，这是一个完美的例子，他们，我的意思是，他们可能查过你的资料，但我们假设他们没有。我的意思是，他们可能不知道你的大学学位，也不知道你上过这个训练营还是那个训练营，但你
providing real value to them. And you knew, they knew that you knew what you were doing. And so they reached out to you and got that process going. That's a real sign. I think it's inspiration for people out there who want to get into the field of you just get in there and start using things and be a part of the vocal part of the community. And that can go a really long way. Yeah, I think one of the things I've noticed when I work with newly onboarded employees is they're very much two types, the ones that need to wait to be told, you know, what to do and how to solve a problem, or they, they always have questions. And then the ones that bring me two solutions to a problem they've encountered and they Google them or stack overflow them and, and found them and say,
在为他们提供真正的价值。而且你知道，他们也知道你知道自己在做什么。所以他们联系了你，并启动了这个流程。这是一个真正的信号。我认为这对那些想要进入这个领域的人来说是一个鼓舞，你只要加入进去，开始使用各种技术，成为社区中积极发言的一员。这能带来长远的发展。是的，我觉得我注意到的一件事是，当我与新入职的员工合作时，他们大致分两类，一类是需要等待别人告诉他们该做什么以及如何解决问题的人，或者他们总是有各种问题；而另一类是，当他们遇到问题时，会带来两种解决方案，他们通过谷歌或 Stack Overflow 找到了它们，然后说，
I don't know which, but both of these would solve the problem. All day long, that makes me do a happy dance inside as opposed to the other. Likewise, when you're working with a product, I know that they don't want their documentation to be outdated. Nobody wants that. I hate documentation, but I was willing to do it because I needed that postman collection to work for me anyway. As soon as I got it to work for me, I'll just send it to them. And that way, nobody else has to have that problem. We have enough problems as programmers. Yeah, that's right.
我不知道哪个更好，但这两个都能解决问题。比起另一类人，整整一天都能让我内心高兴得手舞足蹈。同样，当你与一个产品合作时，我知道他们不希望自己的文档过时。没有人希望那样。我讨厌文档，但我愿意去做，因为无论如何我都需要那个 Postman 集合能为我工作。一旦我让它为我工作了，我就把它发给他们。这样一来，其他人就不会再遇到这个问题了。作为程序员，我们的麻烦已经够多了。是的，没错。
Let's not let them fester out there in the world. Yeah, totally. Cool. Yeah, that's awesome. And so, yeah, that's great. So you were using HarperDB as part of this IoT project. You're communicating with them. And you said, wow, this is actually a really cool piece of technology. I want to go there full time. And also the idea of virtual thing. So let's jump into how do people write code for the edge? And how is that different from, you know, building a regular server like in PHP or something like that? Like what is, what makes the edge environment different to work with? It's a very good question because based on our previous, based on your previous question about what is the edge, I think that's changed for me a lot because for most people,
别让那些问题在世界上继续恶化了。是的，完全同意。太酷了。是的，这太棒了。所以，你在那个物联网项目中使用 HarperDB 作为一部分。你在与他们沟通。然后你说，哇，这实际上是一个非常酷的技术。我想去那里全职工作。还有虚拟办公的想法。所以让我们跳到人们如何为边缘端编写代码？这与构建像 PHP 或类似语言的常规服务器有什么不同？边缘环境有哪些独特的工作体验？这是一个很好的问题，因为根据我们之前的，根据你刚才关于什么是边缘的问题，我觉得我的看法改变了很多，因为对大多数人来说，
I think who've been doing this for a long time, because lots of people have been programming at the edge. And that's, you know, microprocessors written in low level C and, you know, basically super. I mean, you guys were rocket scientists, right? And you worked on things that went into space. So theoretically, you've worked on extremely resource constrained devices. And that always felt to me like what edge was. Edge is, it doesn't do a lot, but it's very purpose-driven. It's not super dynamic. And to be honest, once you put it on that board, it's never going to change. Yeah. Yeah. I think resources have changed and the Raspberry Pi kind of opened everybody's
我想，那些长期从事这项工作的人，因为很多人一直在边缘端进行编程。那就是，用底层 C 语言编写的微处理器，你知道的，基本上是超级……我的意思是，你们是火箭科学家，对吧？你们从事过进入太空的项目。所以理论上，你们一直在处理资源极其受限的设备。这在我的印象中一直是边缘的定义。边缘不做很多事情，但它非常有针对性。它不是超级动态的。老实说，一旦你把它安装到那块板子上，它就永远不会改变了。是的。是的。我认为资源已经改变了，树莓派让每个人都大开眼界，
mind to what was possible and that you've got Arduinos and all of these little things where you can add your custom code and even update it over time to continually adjust to changing workloads. Yeah, really to double click on that, our car connects to the internet. I mean, it's not a fancy, it's just a Honda Odyssey, but it connects to the internet when we get home. And one day we were out driving and I stopped at a red light and the car shut off and I panicked, but it turned out that this was just a new feature that had rolled out where the car literally turns off when you hit a red light. And then when you let go of the brake, it turns itself back on. And I guess that's somehow more economical, but it just randomly happened.
意识到了什么是可能的，你有了 Arduino 以及所有这些小东西，你可以在其中添加自定义代码，甚至随着时间的推移不断更新它，以不断适应不断变化的工作负载。是的，深入探讨一下，我们的车连上了互联网。我的意思是，它不是什么高级货，只是一辆本田奥德赛，但当我们到家时它会连接到互联网。有一天我们开车出门，我在一个红灯前停下，车子熄火了，我当时慌了，但结果证明这只是一个新推出的功能，当你遇到红灯时车子真的会熄火。然后当你松开刹车时，它自己又重新启动了。我想这在某种程度上更省油，但它就是随机发生了。
So we've kind of moved from, when Patrick and I were doing embedded work, there'd be this firmware update and you'd have to carry a briefcase with a laptop in it and a cord, and you'd go to the site and you'd plug it in and update the firmware. And it took thousands of dollars for you to fly halfway across the world to do that. And now my car just does it. I don't even know, right? I mean, it's just so different nowadays. I mean, I do feel like maybe they should send you an email telling you your car is going to shut off starting Friday.
所以我们有点从……当帕特里克和我做嵌入式工作时，会有这样的固件更新，你必须带着一个装有笔记本电脑和电线的公文包，去到现场，把它插上并更新固件。你得花几千美元飞到世界半球的另一端去完成这件事。而现在我的车自己就能搞定。我甚至都不知道，对吧？我的意思是，现在真的是太不一样了。我的意思是，我觉得也许他们应该给你发封电子邮件，告诉你从周五开始你的车会熄火。
You would think, right? It just randomly started happening. Don't freak out, but this is going to start happening. Yeah, but it shows a dramatic change. And to your point, Raspberry Pi is also just a massive game changer because it puts it in everybody's hands. I mean, I needed a lot of handholding to do embedded work, having no background in C or anything like that.
你本来会这么想，对吧？它就那么随机地开始发生了。别惊慌，但这就要开始发生了。是的，但这显示了一个巨大的变化。而且说到树莓派，它也是一个巨大的游戏规则改变者，因为它把这项技术交到了每个人手中。我的意思是，要做嵌入式工作，我需要大量的指导，因为我没有 C 语言或类似语言的背景。
And now with Raspberry Pi, you have an entire Debian OS at the edge, which gives you a ton of flexibility. And so I think as we look at where the edge has moved, it becomes resource. And now you look at AWS Lambda and you look at our new feature custom functions. Realistically, JavaScript is the, and I don't want to start a flame war. I don't want to get you flame war i don't i don't want to get you guys like a million downvotes but javascript is an exceptionally easy language to learn and to be honest if sandboxed properly it can be less it can be as non-dangerous as you want it to be and it can be as performant as you as you architect it so So I feel like it's certainly the future of,
而现在有了树莓派，你在边缘端拥有了一个完整的 Debian 操作系统，这为你提供了大量的灵活性。所以我想，当我们审视边缘端的发展方向时，它变成了资源。现在你看看 AWS Lambda，再看看我们的新功能自定义功能。现实地说，JavaScript 是……我不想引发口水战。我不想让你陷入口水战，我不想让你们招来上百万个踩，但 JavaScript 是一种极其容易学习的语言，说实话，如果沙箱隔离得当，它可以按你所想的那样安全，并且可以按照你的架构设计达到很高的性能。所以我觉得这绝对是未来的发展方向，
I think, at least edge prototyping. I would be hard pressed to say that there is still not going to be a use case once you figure out what you want to do with data at the edge to continually lower costs and perhaps solve that hardware problem permanently. You are going to be on more constrained devices and maybe you're going to use something like a Kotlin
至少在边缘原型设计方面是这样的。我很难说，一旦你弄清楚了你想在边缘端对数据做什么，以持续降低成本并彻底解决硬件问题，就不会再有这样的用例了。你将会使用受到更多限制的设备，也许你会使用类似 Kotlin 这样的语言，
that can compile down and run in the JVM or something that's going to be able to function out there but still has that, I don't know, the mental clock cycles of the developer in mind and the ease of use, the, I don't know, call it the usability, I guess. I want it to be usable because I always call it when we're talking about collecting sensor data and doing workloads at the edge. Right now it's so new. Everybody's been talking about edge
它可以编译并在 JVM 中运行，或者某种能够在边缘运行但仍然考虑到开发人员的心理时钟周期和易用性——我不知道，姑且称之为可用性吧——的东西。我希望它是可用的，因为当我们谈论收集传感器数据和在边缘端处理工作负载时，我总是这么说。现在它太新了。每个人都在谈论边缘
computing for years, but we are collecting so much data. And I call it the Rumsfeldian challenge because we just, we don't know what we don't know. So we better collect everything. And obviously transporting that all to the cloud is not ideal. So we will solve this problem, but I think it takes a lot of experimentation in the very beginning and you need something flexible for that. And so these wholly capable standalone Ubuntu environments like a Raspberry Pi are the ideal place for us to figure out what it is we're even going to do when we're out there at the edge. the AI for the Tesla autopilot. And he was effectively saying, well, we just need to get enough data and then we'll be done. And so it's really a data problem. I think that the challenge, I mean, I agree with him in principle, but practically the challenge is some data is
计算已经好几年了，但我们正在收集如此多的数据。我称之为拉姆斯费尔德式的挑战，因为我们只是……我们对于未知一无所知。所以我们最好把所有东西都收集起来。显然，把所有这些都传输到云端并不是理想的做法。所以我们会解决这个问题，但我认为这在最初需要大量的试验，你需要为此提供一些灵活的东西。因此，这些功能齐全的、像树莓派这样的独立 Ubuntu 环境，是我们弄清楚当我们在边缘端时到底要做什么的理想场所。特斯拉自动驾驶仪的 AI。他的意思是，我们只需要获取足够的数据，然后就完成了。所以这实际上是一个数据问题。我认为挑战在于……我的意思是，我在原则上同意他的观点，但在实际操作中，挑战在于某些数据
more important than others, right? So for example, if you're driving on a road here in Texas and there's nobody on the road and it's 70 mile an hour speed limit and you're just going on a straight road by yourself, that is a lot less interesting than you're part of a 17 car pilot, right? And so that second thing doesn't happen very often, but when it does, it's really important to collect that data
比其他数据更重要，对吧？例如，如果你在德克萨斯州的一条路上开车，路上没有人，限速是 70 英里每小时，而你只是独自一人开在一条直路上，这可比你成为 17 辆车测试车队的一部分要无趣得多，对吧？所以第二种情况不经常发生，但当它发生时，收集这些数据非常重要，
because you want every single time that happens, you want to learn as much as possible, right? Anytime there's a black swan event, you want to learn as much as possible. But as you said, you can't collect everything all the time or even half the time or even a tenth of a time. So you need something that's smart, that's saying, you know, is what's happening right now interesting? If it is, then start collecting it. If it's not, then throw it away. And that smart thing has to live on the edge, you know, by definition. And so I think that the differentiator, and I'm not an autonomous vehicle guy or anything like that, but, but just looking at the Tesla idea, I feel like the differentiator there is, can they do smart things at the edge? That's going to make or break that whole idea.
因为每当那种情况发生时，你都希望尽可能多地学习，对吧？每当出现黑天鹅事件时，你都希望尽可能多地汲取经验。但正如你所说，你不能一直收集所有数据，甚至连一半或十分之一都做不到。所以你需要一些聪明的东西，它能判断：现在发生的事情有趣吗？如果是，那就开始收集。如果不是，那就把它扔掉。而这个聪明的东西必须存在于边缘端，按定义就是这样。所以我觉得区分点在于——我不是自动驾驶汽车专家或类似的人——但仅就特斯拉的想法而言，我觉得那里的区分点在于：它们能在边缘端做聪明的事情吗？这将决定整个想法的成败。
And so I, I think there's probably a hundred other examples where, where edge computing is going to make or break a lot of the next generation of tech and of ideas. I agree. And the classic example that I always talk about, I was working with the oil and gas industry, the turbines that are processing at their refineries, they spend 20,000 RPM. And if something goes wrong, it goes really wrong. And those things shut down and it's at peak natural gas prices. It's a million dollars a day that they're losing for just one turbine. So it shuts down and it's not able to refine it. They're losing a million dollars a day or in some cases a lot more than that. And they were collecting data and pushing it into an old school data historian from sensors. And their resolution was every five seconds. And you can look at the data points leading up to a failure and you can say, well, there's probably something there. Yeah, that's right.
所以，我想可能还有其他上百个例子，边缘计算将在其中决定下一代科技和许多创意成败。我完全同意。我经常谈论的一个经典例子是，我曾与石油天然气行业合作，他们炼油厂里处理天然气流量的涡轮机，转速达到每分钟 20,000 转。如果出了问题，那可就大错特错了。这些涡轮机会关闭，而当时正值天然气价格最高峰。仅仅一台涡轮机他们每天就会损失一百万美元。所以它关闭了，无法进行提炼。他们每天损失一百万美元，有时甚至比这还要多。他们从传感器收集数据并将其推送到老式的数据历史库中。他们的采样分辨率是每五秒一次。你可以查看导致故障的数据点，然后会说，嗯，那里面可能有点东西。是的，没错。
And they had one guy. They introduced me to the one guy. And he comes in and he looks at it, and he's like, well, yeah, here's what happened, and everybody else in the room, we were all looking at the exact same screen, and we had no idea what he was talking about, and he's like, well, I remember once in this other place 20 years ago, I saw something like this. We didn't have sensors back then, but it was a lot like this. And he just had all of his tribal knowledge and he was 60 and he desperately wanted to retire,
他们有一个专家。他们把我引见给那个专家。他走进来，看了一眼，然后说，噢，是的，事情是这样的。而房间里的其他人，我们都看着完全相同的屏幕，却根本不知道他在说些什么。他说，嗯，我记得 20 年前在另一个地方见过类似的情况。我们当时没有传感器，但它非常像这样。他拥有自己所有的部落知识，他已经 60 岁了，迫切地想退休，
but he could not. He would get called up in the middle of the night and have to fly off somewhere in the world to analyze something that had gone wrong. And so our mission in this consulting project with this company was to provide five you know, five millisecond resolution, but you cannot record that and put that all into a historian because you're going to overwhelm that test period. So we built a system that basically kept a rolling buffer of five minutes and would wait for an anomaly to occur, would wait through that anomaly or shut down if that's what happened, and then capture five minutes on the other side, wrap that up into a package, put that into a local edge instance of our product, which would then be transported up to the cloud for analysis.
但他做不到。他会在半夜被叫醒，不得不飞到世界上的某个地方去分析出了什么问题。所以我们在这家公司的咨询项目中的任务是提供……你知道的，五毫秒分辨率的数据，但你不能把这些数据全部记录并放入历史库中，因为那样会压垮测试周期。所以我们构建了一个系统，它基本上保留了一个五分钟的滚动缓冲区，等待异常情况的发生，经历那个异常过程或者在发生关机时记录下来，然后捕获另一侧的五分钟数据，将其打包，放入我们产品的本地边缘实例中，然后传输到云端进行分析。
So the ability to understand what an event is, what data led up to it, and capture that in higher resolution when you're just normal, steady state analysis of five second resolution where you're like, as long as the line is flat, everything's great. But as soon as that line starts to move a little bit and infinitesimally so, and you're talking about vibration, it's something that's spinning at 20,000 RPM. It's important to know all of those fluctuations and important to be able to look at them because not everybody has that tribal knowledge to understand that, you know, when it goes up by a fraction and down by a fraction every five seconds, that what you're really looking at
因此，理解什么是事件、导致该事件的数据是什么，并在正常、稳定的状态分析（即五秒分辨率，此时你觉得只要曲线是平的，一切都很好）下以更高的分辨率捕获这些数据的能力是至关重要的。但一旦这条曲线开始出现哪怕一小部分、甚至无穷小的移动，而且你谈论的是振动时——这是一种以每分钟 20,000 转旋转的东西。了解所有这些波动并能够观察它们非常重要，因为不是每个人都有这种部落知识，能够理解，你知道的，每五秒钟上升一小部分、下降一小部分，你真正看到的是……
is very real problems with vibration in the 24 hours leading up to this thing flying through the wall and ruining everybody's day. Yeah. Yeah. I think the, uh, that problem of, you know, am I seeing something interesting? He's like a really phenomenal, I think it's a type of an active learning problem. And so for something like that. So, so I definitely, you know, I, I, uh, I think, you know, JavaScript is, is, uh, actually I, I truly enjoy writing TypeScript, which compiles down to JavaScript. I feel like it's a solid language. Do you think we'll get to a point
……在事物飞穿墙壁并毁掉所有人的一天之前的 24 小时内，非常真实的振动问题。是的。是的。我认为，呃，那个问题，你知道的，我是否看到了有趣的事情？这就像一个非常了不起的，我认为这是一种主动学习的问题。所以对于这样的事情。所以，所以我绝对，你知道，我，我，呃，我认为，你知道，JavaScript 是，是，实际上我，我真的很喜欢编写编译为 JavaScript 的 TypeScript。我觉得它是一门坚实的语言。你认为我们会达到这样一个时间点吗……
where the edge will be language independent? Or is there something about the edge where if you were to add more languages, it's just a lot of work? Is there something... Could you describe a little bit, what's this machine VM or what's this sort of box that runs at the edge in terms of software and what actually is going on there? Well, I mean, it depends if it's, what we found
……边缘计算将变得与语言无关？还是说边缘计算本身有什么特性，如果你想添加更多语言，那只是需要做大量的工作？有什么……你能稍微描述一下什么是机器虚拟机，或者在软件方面，到底是什么在边缘运行的这种盒子，那里实际上在发生什么？好吧，我的意思是，这取决于它是否是，我们发现……
is that the, the, the opportunity in POCs is that you can put anything out there. It could be any language and the box doesn't need necessarily to even survive the element. So you're not really hardware limited until you go out of proof of concept and into production, right? So once you figure out what your functionality is, then you start to look at what is the cost-effective hardware that can be run and how do I replicate this functionality out there? And from a resource perspective, will I have the benefit of an OS that supports Python? Could I run my statistics in a Python script? Or could I use JavaScript because I want to do a bunch of API calls to third-party resources? Or what language accomplishes my goal for the proof of concept
……概念验证（POCs）的机会在于你可以把任何东西放在那里。它可以是任何语言，而且盒子甚至不需要在恶劣环境中存活下来。所以在你从概念验证进入生产环境之前，你并不是真正的硬件受限，对吧？所以一旦你弄清楚了你的功能是什么，你就会开始寻找什么是可以运行的具有成本效益的硬件，以及我如何在外面复制这个功能？从资源的角度来看，我会享受到支持 Python 的操作系统的优势吗？我可以在 Python 脚本中运行我的统计数据吗？或者我可以使用 JavaScript，因为我想对第三方资源进行一堆 API 调用？或者什么语言能实现我进行概念验证的目标……
may well be different than the language that accomplishes the goal in final production. So in the same way TypeScript compiles down to JavaScript, Kotlin, you know, compiles down to something that runs in a JVM. I'm sure that somebody very smart, you know, is going to take some super easy language that hasn't even been invented yet that my children are going to learn how to write that will compile down to C and ultimately be able to be shipped off through chip as a service. And you're going to send me the thermostat program that my kid wrote to keep her room cooler in the middle of the summer and adjust the thermostat automatically so i feel like i i want to believe that you know language the language shouldn't
……这很可能与在最终生产环境中实现目标的语言不同。因此，就像 TypeScript 编译成 JavaScript 一样，Kotlin，你知道，编译成运行在 JVM 中的东西。我确信某个非常聪明的人，你知道，会采用某种超级简单的语言，这种语言甚至还没有被发明出来，我的孩子们将学习如何编写它，它将编译成 C，并最终能够通过芯片即服务（chip as a service）的形式运输出去。然后你会把我的孩子为了在盛夏让她的房间更凉爽而编写的恒温器程序发给我，并自动调整恒温器，所以我感觉我，我想要相信，你知道，语言，语言不应该……
matter that the programming languages and to whatever end there are you know tribes that adhere and fight desperately for one language over the other, that probably all eventually goes away. And we all just drag and drop some boxes onto a screen and say, that's what I want it to do and go make it happen where I want it to happen. Containerization is obviously a huge movement and it has been in the cloud for applications. We see certainly in these smaller edge data centers, everything is containerized. They're only pushing containers out there nobody's installing on bare metal and you know even at the edge out at the vineyard we are running you know little docker containers
……关系重大，编程语言以及为此目的而存在的（你知道的）坚守并拼死为一个语言而反对另一个语言的阵营，最终可能都会消失。我们大家只需将一些方块拖放到屏幕上，然后说，这就是我想要它做的事情，并在我希望它发生的地方让它发生。容器化显然是一个巨大的运动，它在云端应用程序中一直如此。我们当然在这些较小的边缘数据中心看到，一切都是容器化的。他们只把容器推送到那里，没有人安装在裸金属上，你知道，甚至在葡萄园的边缘，我们也在运行，你知道，小型 docker 容器……
and those raspberry pi's so it's entirely possible to be you know a kubernetes cluster you know pushed out to the edge k33S is a great, really, really minimalist container management platform. But again, I don't know how the code gets out to the edge. And to be honest, I try not to care. I try to work on how does the part of the puzzle that I'm working on, how does it make everybody's life easier rather than more of a problem? Yep. Yep. That makes sense. I'm trying to make it just work. And somebody with a lot more money and a lot more time and who hasn't spent as much of their life banging their head against the hardware problem is probably going to have to solve that one because I think I may
……还有那些树莓派（Raspberry Pi），所以完全有可能，你知道，是一个 Kubernetes 集群，你知道，被推送到边缘。K3S 是一个非常非常简约的容器管理平台。但是话说回来，我不知道代码是如何到达边缘的。说实话，我尽量不去关心。我试着去研究我正在处理的那部分拼图，它如何能让每个人的生活变得更轻松，而不是制造更多问题？是的。是的。这讲得通。我只是想让它能用。而某个拥有更多资金、更多时间、并且没有花那么多生命在硬件问题上撞南墙的人，可能将不得不去解决那个问题，因为我想我可能……
have given up on it. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. I think maybe, you know, it started as a, I believe a lot of these Lambda functions started as, as sort of JavaScript kind of front end servers. And so, and so you have the browser running JavaScript. And so I think maybe it's a starting point that a lot of this, the cloud flare edge, I think is JavaScript only. And that's probably just because of their pedigree, like where they came from and their inspiration. And, but to your point, I think, is JavaScript only. And that's probably just because of their pedigree, like where they came from and their inspiration. But to your point, it's all run on VMs. And so it's just a matter of time before they'll say,
……已经放弃它了。是的，这说得通。是的。我想也许，你知道，它最初是一个，我相信很多这样的 Lambda 函数最初是，某种 JavaScript 种类的前端服务器。所以，所以你有运行 JavaScript 的浏览器。所以我想也许这是一个起点，云flare 边缘的很多东西，我认为是纯 JavaScript。这可能只是因为它们的血统，比如它们的出处和灵感。但是，说到你的点，我认为是纯 JavaScript。这可能只是因为它们的血统，比如它们的出处和灵感。但说到你的点，这一切都在虚拟机上运行。所以这只是时间问题，他们会说……
look, you can point us to your Docker Hub location that could be running just about anything and then just really open it up. It teaches you a lot. As you start to move into real- life deployments where containerization is the standard, it also teaches you how important it is to build a good Docker image. Cause that's one of the things I feel like, I feel like Donald's news,
……看，你可以给我们指出你的 Docker Hub 位置，那里几乎可以运行任何东西，然后真正将其开放。它能教给你很多东西。当你开始进入以容器化为标准的现实世界部署时，它还教给你构建一个好的 Docker 镜像有多么重要。因为我觉得这是其中一件事，我觉得唐纳德的新闻……
Donald Newt's axiom about premature optimization is one of those things that can absolutely kill a company, but man, if you're gonna to spend it anywhere, a good Docker container is key. I think when I got to HarperDB, our Docker container was 350 megs. And I was like, it feels too big. I mean, it literally feels like it might be too big given that our actual installer, our actual installed binary is under a hundred and all we needed was Node.js, no JS, uh, I feel like we could do, we could, we could do this better. So we spent a lot of time just recently, actually with our new release, working on that and making it what we're, I guess, the industry term is a first-class citizen because truly I think containerized applications and workloads, and to be honest, dynamically distributed by large service providers that
……唐纳德·努思（Donald Knuth）关于过早优化的公理是绝对可以杀死一家公司的东西之一，但是天哪，如果你要在任何地方花心思，一个好的 Docker 容器就是关键。我想当我来到 HarperDB 时，我们的 Docker 容器是 350 兆。当时我想，这感觉太大了。我的意思是，考虑到我们的实际安装程序、我们的实际安装二进制文件不到 100 兆，而我们需要的只是 Node.js，没有 JS，呃，我觉得我们可以做得更好，我们完全可以做得更好。所以我们最近花了很多时间，实际上是随着我们的新release，致力于研究这个，并把它打造成我们所认为的——我猜行业术语叫“一等公民”（first-class citizen），因为确实我认为容器化的应用程序和工作负载，说实话，由大型服务提供商动态分发……
provide rapid access to your application on demand, they don't want your Docker container running out on their edge servers all of the time. They may only want to follow the sun. And right now, the best framework we have for that is something like a Kubernetes cluster that can shut down and spin up and have access to persistent disks, certainly for data storage. But a lot of it is ephemeral. Yeah, that makes sense. I had an issue recently with AWS Lambda, where I think Lambda can only be 200 meg. That's their limit. And so I wanted to run some machine learning. And as anyone knows,
……按需为您的应用程序提供快速访问，他们不希望您的 Docker container 一直在他们的边缘服务器上运行。他们可能只想“逐日”（follow the sun）。目前，我们拥有的最佳框架类似于 Kubernetes 集群，它可以关闭和启动，并可以访问持久磁盘，当然是为了数据存储。但其中很多是短暂的。是的，这说得通。我最近遇到了一个关于 AWS Lambda 的问题，我觉得 Lambda 只能有 200 兆。那是他们的限制。所以我想运行一些机器学习。正如任何人都知道的……
who's tried to install PyTorch or TensorFlow or any of these things, like you type, you know, pip install PyTorch, and then you get this, this, you know, in console progress bar telling you you're downloading like 900 megabytes. And you're like, what, you know, but it's just, I think it's because it has all these different optimizers, you know, if you're running, what? But I think it's because it has all these different optimizers. If you're running on Intel hardware, there's this thing called MKL, which is some kind of linear algebra thing. And if you're running on the GPU, they have that. And so it ends up being this massive thing that really can't be, at least I don't know how to decompose it. And so I think I ended up getting around that with some elastic
……任何尝试安装 PyTorch、TensorFlow 或任何这些东西的人，就像你输入，你知道的，pip install PyTorch，然后你就会得到这个，这个，你知道的，控制台进度条，告诉你你正在下载大约 900 兆字节的数据。然后你会想，什么，你知道的，但这只是，我想这是因为它有所有这些不同的优化器，你知道，如果你在运行，什么？但我想这是因为它有所有这些不同的优化器。如果你在 Intel 硬件上运行，有一个叫做 MKL 的东西，它是一种线性代数的东西。如果你在 GPU 上运行，他们有那个东西。所以它最终变成了这个庞大的东西，真的无法被——至少我不知道如何分解它。所以我认为我最终通过某种弹性……
file system. So now Lambda function mounts this file system that Amazon is just holding onto for you. And you can have a bunch of Lambda functions all using this. But yeah, I think you start to hit a lot of limitations for good reason, because you're fanning this out now. It's not just some server that could be uber powerful sitting in the Midwest somewhere, but you're fanning this out now. It's not just some server that could be uber powerful sitting in the Midwest somewhere, but you're fanning this out to many, many different nodes, potentially all over the world. And so that just creates a lot of limitations
……文件系统绕过了这个问题。所以现在 Lambda 函数挂载了 Amazon 专门为你保留的这个文件系统。你可以有一堆 Lambda 都在使用它。但是是的，你开始遇到很多限制，这是有充分理由的，因为你现在把这个分发（fan this out）出去了。它不仅仅是一些可能超级强大、坐在中西部某个地方的服务器，而是你现在把这个分发到了许多许多不同的节点，可能遍布全世界。所以这只会产生大量的限制……
that people might've not had to deal with otherwise. It creates a tremendous number of limitations. I mean, it also creates a lot of opportunity for the challenges around logistics and that's the other thing that kubernetes you know for better or worse is very good at it's like i have an atom and i want this atom to do some work and i wanted to do some work here across all of these places and it's very easy to script it and it's very easy to spin it up and it's very easy to spin it down and that is that is truly you know as the container sizes get smaller and as the edge compute resources become more powerful you know you're just going to continue to push out and i
……人们可能不得不应对其他情况。它产生了极大量的限制。我的意思是，它也为物流方面的挑战创造了很多机会，而这正是 kubernetes（无论好坏）非常擅长的另一件事，就像我有一个原子，我希望这个原子做一些工作，我希望它在这里的所有这些地方做一些工作，编写脚本非常容易，启动它非常容易，关闭它也非常容易，而且这确实是，你知道的，随着容器尺寸变小以及边缘计算资源变得更强大，你知道的，你只会继续向外推进，我……
don't see any change in in you know containerized architectures coming because I can't imagine a better, more atomic way to send out a core piece of functionality than in that container. I mean, would I like it to have less overhead? Sure. Would I like it to be a little less complex? Yes. But it does a great job. And that's why DevOps people are so angry all the time. Yeah, that's right. I think, and you could please fill in the gaps here, but I think the way that the container system works is it's kind of like you start with some base image and then it keeps download Node.js and install it. You know, those commands are run starting from some frame of reference. Maybe it's an Ubuntu install or something like that. And so, you know, you don't have to actually copy the Ubuntu install because that's sort of your base image that everyone has agreed on.
……看不到容器化架构会有什么改变，因为我想不出比在这个容器中发送核心功能更好、更具原子性的方式了。我的意思是，我希望它有更少的开销吗？当然。我希望它不那么复杂吗？是的。但它做得很好。这就是为什么 DevOps 人员总是那么生气。是的，没毛病。我想，你可以请在这里填补空白，但我认为容器系统的运作方式有点像是你从某种基础镜像开始，然后它不断下载 Node.js 并安装它。你知道，这些命令是从某个参考框架开始运行的。也许它是 Ubuntu 安装或类似的东西。所以，你知道，你实际上不必复制 Ubuntu 安装，因为那是每个人都同意的基础镜像。
This is the Ubuntu image. But you're copying over basically what you've done to that image. And so I guess, and walk us through this, but like shrinking the Docker container in this case, I guess means just, does it mean doing less things to the base image so that there's less to keep there? Well, there's a process called like a sequential build where you could bring in the Ubuntu image and then you install Node.js. But all you really need is Node.js because on top of Node.js, which is the only prerequisite for HarperDB, you install HarperDB. And so rather than carry the whole Ubuntu image, because again,
这就是 Ubuntu 镜像。但你基本上是在复制你对那个镜像所做的事情。所以我想，带我们了解一下这个过程，缩小这里的 Docker 容器，我想这意味着，这是否意味着对基础镜像做更少的事情，以便留在那里东西更少？嗯，有一个叫做顺序构建（sequential build）的过程，你可以引入 Ubuntu 镜像，然后你安装 Node.js。但你真正需要的只是 Node.js，因为在 Node.js 之上——它是 HarperDB 的唯一先决条件——你安装 HarperDB。所以，与其携带整个 Ubuntu 镜像，因为话说回来……
these are going to be installed over a Linux OS, right? That's what's running Docker or Linux subsystem on Windows. So you've got Linux. You don't need all of Ubuntu. You definitely need Node.js because we require that. So ultimately you want to install Node.js and there are Node.js based images, and then you can install HarperDB on top of that. And then in our case, because we persist to disk, and we're not just reading from inbound streaming data, we need to persist something, your data and your config. We, on container start, will the first time install, i.e. reach out to that persistent disk, set up all the files that we need, set up your config, set up your data store, set up your data files. And then ultimately
……这些将安装在 Linux 操作系统上，对吧？这就是在 Windows 上运行 Docker 或 Linux 子系统的内容。所以你有了 Linux。你不需要整个 Ubuntu。你绝对需要 Node.js，因为我们需要它。所以最终你想安装 Node.js，并且有基于 Node.js 的镜像，然后你可以在其之上安装 HarperDB。然后对我们来说，因为我们持久化到磁盘，而且我们不仅仅是从传入的流数据中读取，我们需要持久化一些东西，你的数据和你的配置。我们，在容器启动时，将第一次安装，即连接到该持久磁盘，设置我们需要的所有文件，设置你的配置，设置你的数据存储，设置你的数据文件。然后最终……
that becomes your install. So it's not plug and play because otherwise we wouldn't be able to persist any data, but it is as quick as it can be that first time. And then if it were to shut down and start up, it will look at its persisted disk, its file mount basically, and say, oh, well, all of those install files are there, so I'm good. I'm just going to basically spin up the APIs that HarperDB has and wait for somebody to try to talk to me. Got it. I see. And if it reads those files and it says this is a version eight of HarperDB, but on version nine, and it has some migration logic and all of that. Exactly. Got it. Cool. Cool. That makes sense. So cool. So let's dive into databases now. So we have, I think we've given a really good overview of edge computing. And so you kind of, you can see
……这就成了你的安装。所以它不是即插即用的，否则我们将无法持久化任何数据，但它是第一次时尽可能快的。然后如果它关闭并启动，它将查看其持久磁盘，基本上是其文件挂载，然后说，哦，好吧，所有这些安装程序文件都在那里，所以我很好。我基本上只需启动 HarperDB 拥有的 API，然后等待有人试图与我对话。明白了。我懂了。如果它读取了这些文件，并且说这是 HarperDB 的第八版，但现在是第九版，并且它有一些迁移逻辑以及所有这些。完全正确。明白了。酷。酷。这讲得通。太酷了。那么我们现在深入探讨数据库。所以我们有，我想我们已经对边缘计算进行了非常好的概述。所以你可以那种，你可以看到……
kind of how this can follow. You have all these machines running, let's say, in the vineyard, and they want to do things without having to phone home. So they don't want to have to give all the data to some server, which could be a thousand miles away. They want to do some processing locally, a lot of processing locally, and then just send back the most important things. And so to do that and to coordinate that, we need to have some centralized place where we can have information. So to use the vineyard as an example, you know, maybe we want a centralized place where we store
……这可以如何跟进。你所有的机器都在运行，比方说在葡萄园里，它们想要在不给总部打电话（phone home）的情况下做事。所以它们不想把所有数据都交给某个可能在千里之外的服务器。它们想在本地进行一些处理，大量的本地处理，然后只把最重要的东西发回。因此，为了做到这一点并进行协调，我们需要有一个集中式的地方来存储信息。以葡萄园为例，你知道，也许我们想要一个集中式的地方来存储……
what we consider to be like anomalous temperatures. And that could change as the season changes. And so we want to keep some information in all of these Raspberry Pis so that they're all kind of on the same page and they can kind of make decisions kind of as a unit, right? And so what you end up having to do is, if you were to write this by hand,
……我们认为的异常温度。随着季节的变化，这可能会改变。所以我们想在所有这些树莓派中保留一些信息，这样它们都在同一页上，它们可以作为一个整体做出决策，对吧？所以你最终要做的是，如果你要手写这段代码……
is do a lot of message passing. And anyone who's, you know, and I wrote Mame Hub a long time ago. So it's a peer-to-peer kind of video game thing. You know, anyone who's ever done peer-to-peer knows how hard it is. You know, getting two Raspberry Pis to talk to each other,
……就是做大量的消息传递。任何曾经，你知道的，我很久以前写过 Mame Hub。所以它是一种点对点的视频游戏东西。你知道，任何做过点对点（peer-to-peer）的人都知道这有多难。你知道，让两个树莓派互相交谈……
you know, unless they have a public IP address is super difficult. And just having a mesh network, even a mesh network of public computers, is really difficult. So kind of walk us through, like, what is kind of HarperDB? How does it solve this problem? And why is it able to do what it does? Sure. So HarborDB was built by developers. I love the phrase, by developers, for developers. It feels like every product is that, really, isn't it?
……除非它们有公共 IP 地址，否则超级困难。仅仅拥有一个网状网络（mesh network），即使是公共计算机的网状网络，也非常困难。所以请带我们了解一下，比如，什么是 HarperDB？它是如何解决这个问题的？为什么它能够做到它所做的事情？当然。所以 HarborDB 是由开发者构建的。我喜欢这句话：由开发者构建，为开发者服务。感觉每个产品都是这样，真的，不是吗？
Well, maybe not for developers, but definitely by developers. You got to have that. Ultimately, it was built to solve a lot of the pain points that we found when we were building distributed applications. So I know that I have workloads that I want to run on disparate devices. I know that I'm going to collect some sensor data. I know that I want to run some calculations on that. I know that sometimes the sensor data comes in more quickly than I can run those calculations. And sometimes it comes in less quickly. I need to persist that in some way. So I'm writing it to a file or I'm holding it in RAM, except I lose power. And now all of a sudden I've lost all the data I was holding or, or I was able to make my calculation. And now I've reduced that stream of data to
嗯，也许不是为开发者服务，但绝对是由开发者构建的。你必须具备这一点。最终，它的构建是为了解决我们在构建分布式应用程序时发现的大量痛点。我知道我有想在不同设备上运行的工作负载。我知道我将收集一些传感器数据。我知道我想对其进行一些计算。我知道有时传感器数据进入的速度比我运行这些计算的速度还要快。有时它来的比较慢。我需要以某种方式持久化它。所以我把它写到一个文件里，或者把它保存在内存中，除非我断电了。现在突然之间我失去了我一直持有的所有数据，或者，或者我能够进行我的计算。现在我已经把那个数据流减少到……
the every 10 minute running average that I really want. And I have that 10 minute running average. And now I want to transmit that 10 minute running average to the next data point in that 10 minute running average off to the server that's going to analyze all of the 10 minute running averages across all of my data sensors that I'm collecting, except I lost my network connection. So now I need to build a buffer to hold that.
……我真正想要的每 10 分钟运行一次的平均值。我有了那个 10 分钟的运行平均值。现在我想将那个 10 分钟的运行平均值传输到该 10 分钟运行平均值中的下一个数据点，发送到将要分析我收集的所有数据传感器的所有 10 分钟运行平均值的服务器，除非我失去了网络连接。所以我现在需要构建一个缓冲区来保存它。
And oh, wait, somebody shut off the power again. So I lost my buffer. So that's a giant pain. And HarperDB is designed to function and to push that data storage out to the edge. So you can run your calculation, or sorry, you can collect your data from the sensor with app process.
哦，等等，有人又把电源关了。所以我丢失了缓冲区。所以这是一个巨大的痛点。而 HarperDB 的设计旨在运行并将该数据存储推送到边缘。所以你可以运行你的计算，或者抱歉，你可以用应用程序进程从传感器收集你的数据……
And then you can simply put it into the database. Then you can have a, and it is persistent and it is ACID compliant. And you know that it's been stored. And then you can have a second process that will pull those things out and aggregate your 10 minute averages. And then it runs every 10 minutes and then it puts the result into a second table. And that table is now persisted and it is there and we know that we have it. And the fact that you want to now move that data over to, say, the cloud node for analysis, we have what we call clustering, which is not traditional database clustering, but we call our bi-directional table level data replication. So you don't have to replicate an entire database with HarperDB. You can literally choose within a schema or a table what records, sorry, what tables are going
……然后你可以简单地把它放进数据库里。然后你可以有一个，它是持久的并且是符合 ACID 的。并且你知道它已经被存储了。然后你可以有第二个进程，将这些东西拉出来并聚合你的 10 分钟平均值。然后它每 10 分钟运行一次，然后将结果放入第二个表中。该表现在是持久的并且它在那里，我们知道我们拥有它。事实上，你现在想把数据转移到，比方说，用于分析的云节点，我们有所谓的集群（clustering），这不是传统的数据库集群，我们称之为我们的双向表级数据复制（bi-directional table level data replication）。所以你不需要用 HarperDB 复制整个数据库。你实际上可以在模式或表中选择哪些记录，抱歉，哪些表将要……
which direction. I can publish it up. I could subscribe to say a thresholds table that might bring the thresholds for an alert down to the edge. And then when I create my 10 minute running average, I can publish that table up to the cloud. So my when I create my 10 minute running average, I can publish that table up to the cloud. So my application gets a lot simpler because I only need to make local host calls. I don't need to worry about network connectivity. I don't need to worry about holding in a memory buffer. I don't need to worry about what happens if the power goes off because I know it's persisted. I don't need to worry about, you know, wifi going out or, or whatever mesh network collapsing for a few seconds because somebody kicked a power cord. It's there. And when it gets plugged back in and HarperDB boots back up, it's going to say, oh, I've got these messages. Oh, I have not sent them. I'm going to send them now. And they'll send that. So really, if you look at what HarperDB does, it allows you to simplify your programming by just sitting there being an always on, always connected data fabric. So you can move your data
……走向哪个方向。我可以把它发布上去。我可以订阅一个阈值表，它可能会把警报的阈值带到边缘。然后当我创建我的 10 分钟运行平均值时，我可以把那个表发布到云端。所以我的——当我创建我的 10 分钟运行平均值时，我可以把那个表发布到云端。所以我的应用程序变得简单多了，因为我只需要进行本地主机调用。我不需要担心网络连接。我不需要担心把它保存在内存缓冲区中。我不需要担心如果电源断了会发生什么，因为我知道它是持久的。我不需要担心，你知道的，wifi 断开，或者，或者任何网状网络因为有人踢了电源线而崩溃几秒钟。它就在那里。当它重新插上电源且 HarperDB 重新启动时，它会说，哦，我有这些消息。哦，我还没有发送它们。我现在要发送它们。然后它们就会发送。所以真的，如果你看看 HarperDB 的做什么，它允许你通过坐在那里作为一个始终在线、始终连接的数据结构来简化你的编程。所以你可以移动你的数据……
wherever you need, and you can do operations on it, and you don't need to move all of it. But ultimately, it reduces your application code to just making local calls. So it also, to some degree, allows you to bolt down that box a little more because you don't need your application code to be making calls out to third-party APIs. You could have a cloud server making those calls, putting the results of those calls into HarperDB, and then subscribing those calls, the results of that data, back down to a third-party API call table. And so I don't need to make those calls, the results of that data, back down to a third-party API call table. And so I don't need to make those calls from the edge.
……无论你需要去哪里，你都可以在上面进行操作，而且你不需要移动所有这些数据。但归根结底，它将你的应用程序代码简化为仅仅进行本地调用。因此，在某种程度上，它还允许你稍微锁定那个盒子，因为你不需要你的应用程序代码去调用第三方的 API。你可以让云服务器进行这些调用，将这些调用的结果放入 HarperDB，然后将这些调用、该数据的订阅结果，订阅回第三方 API 调用表。所以我不需要从边缘进行这些调用。
Wow, that's cool. So how does the developer handle conflicts, right? So power goes out. You say that the rolling average is X, but because the power went out, someone else got there first, and they think the rolling average should be Y. Power comes back on, and now you have a conflict. Is there some API to handle that? Or is there something about the way the transactions are specified that there's always a logical way that gets resolved? How does that work? There is. In most of the instances that I'm
哇，太酷了。那么开发者如何处理冲突呢？对吧？断电了。你说滚动平均值是 X，但因为断电了，其他人先到了，他们认为滚动平均值应该是 Y。电源恢复了，现在你有了冲突。有没有什么 API 可以处理这个问题？还是说事务指定的方式中存在某种始终可以得到解决的逻辑方式？这是怎么运作的？有的。在我提到的绝大多数实例中……
kind of describing, add node of HarperDB with a piece of compute, maybe some sensors hanging off the side of it. There won't be a conflict because the rolling average that I'm calculating is based on the sensors that I'm attached to this particular node. So there may be a thousand nodes, but their rolling average is going to be basically tied to their sensors. So there wouldn't be a conflict. However, when you're looking at other applications where perhaps my edge unit is not a Raspberry Pi in a field collecting sensor data, but instead is an edge node in one of those smaller data centers
……将 HarperDB 节点与计算能力、可能挂在它旁边的一些传感器结合起来。不会有冲突，因为我正在计算的滚动平均值是基于连接到这个特定节点的传感器的。所以可能会有一千个节点，但它们的滚动平均值基本上会绑定到它们的传感器。所以不会有冲突。然而，当你看着其他应用程序时，也许我的边缘单元不是田地里收集传感器数据的树莓派，而是那些较小数据中心之一中的边缘节点……
and a user logs on and because of their IP address and their location, they're steered to one and they input some data into a form and that immediately is replicated up to the cloud, which powers the massive UI for the core application. However, somebody else is elsewhere and they may have entered a number into that value a little bit after, but their network connection was a little bit faster, and they get it there first.
……并且用户登录，由于他们的 IP 地址和位置，他们被引导到其中一个，他们在表单中输入一些数据，这立即被复制到云端，为核心应用程序的大型 UI 提供动力。然而，其他人身在别处，他们可能在稍后一点在该值中输入了一个数字，但他们的网络连接稍微快一点，他们先把它弄到了那里。
So the way HarperDB handles that is we have timestamps and we look at a unified time server and say, this timestamp versus this timestamp, whoever last writer wins, and we can overwrite that. But there are often times where that will cause a further conflict where you can get into that. Ultimately, it's an age-old problem in distributed computing. And that is the conflict between data happening over a slow versus a fast network connection. And so our next chapter or our next version, or maybe two versions away, forget, we're looking at CRDTs, which are conflict-free replicated data types. So they have a bunch more metadata associated with them.
所以 HarperDB 处理这个问题的方式是，我们有时间戳，我们查看一个统一的时间服务器并说，这个时间戳与这个时间戳相比，最后写入者获胜（last writer wins），我们可以覆盖它。但通常情况下，这会导致进一步的冲突，你会陷入其中。归根结底，这是分布式计算中一个古老的问题。这就是在慢速与快速网络连接之间发生的数据冲突。所以我们的下一个章节或我们的下一个版本，或者可能隔两个版本，我忘了，我们正在关注 CRDT，即无冲突复制数据类型（conflict-free replicated data types）。所以它们带有更多与之相关的元数据。
And they can therefore make comparisons and say, all right, I know you wanted to do this, but I have to handle this transaction first, even though it came in later. So while I have persisted you, I'm going to unwind you and rerun this and now run you. And the end result is going to be what was intended. Right now, you can do that with HarperDB simply through intelligent architecture. But if our motto is it should just work and, you know, sacrifice simplicity without sacrifice, which is our tagline, ultimately we should handle that for people automatically. So we always have an eye on that. And we're working, we're new enough that we're working with customers and we help them architect these solutions because, you know, distributed computing is a challenge for a lot of people that is new to them. And so we're not the subject matter experts. We're not the only subject matter experts, but we feel like we have a good handle on how we can architect around some of the limitations of existing solutions. And we're always looking forward to try to figure out what the best
因此它们可以进行比较并说，好吧，我知道你想这么做，但我必须先处理这个事务，尽管它来得晚一些。所以虽然我已经持久化了你，但我将解开你并重新运行这个，现在运行你。最终的结果将是预期中的那样。现在，你可以通过智能架构在 HarperDB 中做到这一点。但如果我们的座右铭是“它应该刚刚好”（it should just work）并且“牺牲简单性而不做牺牲”（sacrifice simplicity without sacrifice，这是我们的标语），最终我们应该为人们自动处理这个问题。所以我们一直都在关注这一点。而且我们正在努力，我们还很年轻，正在与客户合作，我们帮助他们构建这些解决方案，因为，你知道的，分布式计算对于许多对他们来说是新事物的人来说是一个挑战。所以我们不是主题专家。我们不是唯一的主题专家，但我们觉得我们对如何围绕现有局限性构建架构有很好的把握，并且我们一直在期待弄清楚什么是最好的……
long-term solution is going to be. Yeah, I remember reading about this with Bitcoin, where it's called the double spend problem, where basically two people are in different geographic regions, or maybe a better way of saying it, who are somehow far apart in the internet space, can both spend the same money at the same time. And then it might take a really long time for that to get resolved. And until it's fully resolved, if someone actually executes that spend, then now you've both been able to buy a coffee for the same price or something like that. And again, I'm not a crypto expert either,
……长期解决方案将是什么。是的，我记得在比特币中读到过这一点，它被称为双花问题（double spend problem），基本上两个人处于不同的地理位置，或者换个更好的说法，在互联网空间中相距甚远，可以同时花掉相同的钱。然后这可能需要很长时间才能解决。在完全解决之前，如果有人真的执行了该花费，那么现在你们俩都能以相同的价格买一杯咖啡或类似的东西。再次说明，我也不是加密货币专家……
but I think that what's going on there is there's, I guess like there's just, it becomes a kind of popularity contest where there's this big battle over who is right. And eventually there's a consensus. And so I would imagine, yeah, something like if you're using HarperDB for e out further and further and closer to the edge because you want to get low response times and you want to get that request. But then for most architectures, at least currently, there's one master database because that's how you solve that problem. And it's a giant vertically scaled instance that costs hundreds of thousands of dollars a month
……但我认为那里发生的事情是，我猜这就像是一场人气竞赛，有一场关于谁是对的巨大争夺。最终达成共识。所以我可以想象，是的，如果你在将 HarperDB 用于……那么你就会越来越深入、越来越接近边缘，因为你想要获得低响应时间和请求。但对于大多数架构，至少目前而言，有一个主数据库，因为那是你解决该问题的方法。这是一个巨大的纵向扩展实例，每月花费数十万美元……
sitting in Oregon. And ultimately you're going to overwhelm it with a thousand different servers running your Lambdas that are all going back to the same place. And we did a proof of concept with a large social company. And if you were in Buenos Aires and you hit their API, the ping to the endpoint, like the connection was almost instantaneous because they had a lambda running in South America in a data center. The data that would come back, your friends list took sometimes upwards of 11 seconds because it was all the way back in
……坐在俄勒冈州。最终，成千上万台运行 Lambda 的不同服务器都会返回同一个地方，从而压垮它。我们与一家大型社交公司做了一个概念验证，如果你在布宜诺斯艾利斯并点击他们的 API，到端点的 ping，就像连接几乎是瞬间完成的，因为他们在南美洲的一个数据中心运行了一个 lambda。将要返回的数据，你的好友列表有时需要长达 11 秒的时间，因为它一路返回到了……
so we ultimately realized that our benefit was we can handle pushing the data out to the edge we can handle with our new custom functions lambdas that are at the edge also so you're you're basically your data is right next to your Lambda that's trying to access it. And then we handle moving the data around and the data that we move around and replicate to all the other instances in a globally replicated cluster of HarperDB is the transaction. It can be as large as the initial operation, but it can also be smaller because it might not change everything at the end of the day. So we can move less data around and we can move it on pipe that we control because we understand the internal IP addresses, which are going to be faster than traditional external IP addresses. And it becomes a homogenous data set with very, very low latency for everybody who's interacting on it.
……所以我们最终意识到，我们的优势在于我们可以处理将数据推送到边缘，我们也可以处理位于边缘的新的自定义函数 lambda。所以你的数据基本上就在试图访问它的 Lambda 旁边。然后我们处理在全局复制的 HarperDB 集群中四处移动数据，我们四处移动并复制到所有其他实例的数据是事务。它的大小可以和初始操作一样大，但它也可以更小，因为它可能最终不会改变所有东西。因此我们可以移动更少的数据，并且我们可以在我们控制的管道上移动它，因为我们了解内部 IP 地址，这会比传统的外部 IP 地址更快。它变成了一个同构数据集，对于与之交互的每个人来说都具有非常非常低的延迟。
And now literally the only challenge that remains is to make sure that multiple actors acting on data at the same time are resolved correctly. So we say we are ACID compliant at the node and we are eventually consistent. So right now we can't do, for example, financial services, right? We're not going to solve that double spend problem. But there are a lot of places where that's not critical. Social media is certainly one of us, but we're working on a solution that would make us able to solve that problem. Very cool. So we talked about kind of mining equipment and some of these like really specialized environment. What about if someone is, here's a good example. What if someone's just building an email app? So an email
现在字面上剩下的唯一挑战是确保同时对数据进行操作的多个参与者能够被正确解决。所以我们说我们在节点上是符合 ACID 的，并且我们是最终一致的（eventually consistent）。所以现在我们不能做，例如，金融服务，对吧？我们不会解决那个双花问题。但有很多地方这并不是关键。社交媒体肯定是其中之一，但我们正在研究一个能让我们解决这个问题的解决方案。非常酷。所以我们谈到了采矿设备和一些这种真正专门的环境。如果有人正在，这里有个好例子。如果有人只是在构建一个电子邮件应用程序呢？所以一个电子邮件……
iPhone app, right? So, you know, they would want to have access to their emails. Obviously the server has a copy of their emails. It's kind of caching, but it's also really more like a database. I mean, you could imagine someone wanting all of their emails on their device, right? And so could someone use HarperDB for something like that? I mean, that's more of like a consumer facing, you know, like on their consumer device running an instance of HarperDB. Is that part of the sort of use space for that?
……iPhone 应用程序，对吧？所以，你知道，他们会想要访问他们的电子邮件。显然服务器有一份他们的电子邮件副本。这有点像缓存，但它其实更像是一个数据库。我的意思是，你可以想象有人希望他们设备上有他们所有的电子邮件，对吧？所以有人可以为这样的事情使用 HarperDB 吗？我的意思是，这更像是一个面向消费者的，你知道的，在他们的消费者设备上运行 HarperDB 实例。这属于那类使用空间的用例吗？
Absolutely. We don't run, we need Node.js, so we're not going to run on an iOS device. We were able to use Userland, which is an Android app that actually installs a Linux subsystem, a full Ubuntu copy, and we could run it there. It was not a recommended implementation, but you certainly can do it. You can get it running on an Android tablet. I built a vehicle telemetry app on a tablet that was completely self-contained. And it would store local data in HarperDB. And then when the tablet came within Wi-Fi range of the office, it would then replicate
绝对可以。我们不运行，我们需要 Node.js，所以我们将无法在 iOS 设备上运行。我们能够使用 Userland，这是一个实际上安装了 Linux 子系统（完整的 Ubuntu 副本）的 Android 应用程序，我们可以在那里运行它。这不是一个推荐的实现方式，但你绝对可以做到。你可以让它在 Android 平板电脑上运行。我在平板电脑上构建了一个完全自包含的车载遥测应用程序。它会在 HarperDB 中存储本地数据。然后当平板电脑进入办公室的 Wi-Fi 范围时，它就会复制……
that data into the cloud. And you would see the vehicle and its path and any violations from its thresholds immediately represented. So if it had cell service, it would be doing that in real time. If I shut off cell service, it would still collect that data, still persist that data. And when it had a network connection, it would push that up. So it's very, very possible to persist that data without maintaining that connection. And I think I forgot what the literal question was. Oh, yeah. So the question was, could you run HarperDB on an iPhone if you're building some app that needs a window of the data locally? So imagine I'm building an email app,
……将该数据导入云端。你会立即看到车辆及其路径以及来自其阈值的任何违规行为的呈现。所以如果它有蜂窝网络服务，它就会实时这样做。如果我关闭蜂窝网络服务，它仍然会收集该数据，仍然会持久化该数据。当它有网络连接时，它就会把它推上去。所以在不保持该连接的情况下持久化该数据是完全完全可能的。我想我忘了字面上的问题是什么。哦，对。所以问题是，如果你正在构建一些需要在本地拥有数据窗口的应用程序，你可以在 iPhone 上运行 HarperDB 吗？所以想象一下我正在构建一个电子邮件应用程序……
I go to airplane mode, I still want to see my emails, I delete a few, I come off airplane mode, it needs to sync. All of that sounds, I would put that in the hard category in terms of being able to do that correctly, where I don't delete the wrong email or have a double delete or something. And so it'd be amazing if there was, and there might, I haven't done a survey on this, but it'd be amazing if there was some technology out there where I could just use some library and I would have some snap, some, some, not snapshot, but some slice of the data locally on my phone and they would take care of everything else, which it sounds like what Harper's doing.
……我进入飞行模式，我仍然想看到我的电子邮件，我删除了几个，我退出飞行模式，它需要同步。所有这些听起来，我会把它归入困难类别，就能够正确地做到这一点而言，我不会删除错误的电子邮件或发生双重删除或类似的事情。所以如果能有，那就太棒了，可能也有，我没有做过这方面的调查，但如果能有一些技术，我可以使用某个库，并且在我的手机上有本地的数据快照，不，不是快照，而是本地的数据切片，并且他们会照顾好其他一切，这听起来像是 Harper 正在做的事情。
And then that's when you brought up the, the restriction around the, the Node.js and all of that. Yeah. And there are, there are pure like client side, JavaScript browser level, JavaScript libraries that, that can accomplish a lot of what we do. They'll make use of IndexedDB as an underlying key value store. We have an underlying key value store that we use called LMDB, which is Lightning Memory Map Database, which is extremely fast, very performant, written in C, but obviously it's just a key value store.
然后这就是你提出围绕 Node.js 的限制以及所有这些的时候。是的。并且有，有纯粹的客户端 JavaScript 浏览器级 JavaScript 库，可以完成我们所做的大部分工作。它们将利用 IndexedDB 作为底层键值存储。我们有一个底层的键值存储，叫做 LMDB，即闪电内存映射数据库（Lightning Memory Map Database），它极其快速，性能很高，用 C 语言编写，但显然它只是一个键值存储。
So it doesn't have all of the properties that you'd want in a database, SQL querying and indexing and stuff like that. So we've built all of HarvardDB's functionality on top of that. However, underlying that is a key value store. So could we, if we had unlimited time and resources, replicate all of that into just a client-side library that you could include in a browser app, have it sync data down from a cloud and be completely performant, self-standalone. And if your browser on your phone then reconnected to a network later, execute the exact sort of syncing that HarperDB does currently
所以它没有你希望在数据库中拥有的所有属性，比如 SQL 查询、索引等等。所以我们在它之上构建了 HarperDB 的所有功能。然而，其底层是一个键值存储。所以，如果我们有无限的时间和资源，能不能将所有这些复制到一个纯客户端库中，你可以将其包含在浏览器应用程序中，让它从云端同步数据并且完全具有高性能、完全独立？如果你的手机上的浏览器稍后重新连接到网络，执行 HarperDB 目前所做的精确同步……
from, say, Raspberry Pi or a smaller data center edge node. Absolutely. You could 100% do that. And there are a few solutions that do that. The challenge is they maintain those subscriptions. Maintaining those subscriptions is expensive on the server. So continually syncing that data back and forth and holding what is in effect a socket open so that you can subscribe to a specific query from, say, a server-side entity is very expensive. Subscribing to a table is a lot less specific because you're going to have a lot less individual subscriptions. It's not that customized. Once you start getting those query level subscriptions, it can become very expensive. Meteor.js was a great platform that did that. And it was built on top of MongoDB and it looked at transaction log to figure out what
……比方说从树莓派或较小的数据中心边缘节点。绝对可以。你 100% 可以做到这一点。并且有一些解决方案可以做到这一点。挑战在于它们维护这些订阅。维护这些订阅在服务器上代价高昂。因此，来回持续同步该数据并保持实际上是打开的套接字，以便你可以订阅来自（比方说）服务器端实体的特定查询，代价非常昂贵。订阅一个表要没那么具体，因为你将拥有少得多得多的单个订阅。它没有那么定制化。一旦你开始获得那些查询级别的订阅，它就会变得非常昂贵。Meteor.js 是一个很好的平台，它做到了这一点。它是建立在 MongoDB 之上的，它查看事务日志以弄清楚……
real-time data needed to be pushed down, but it was incredibly resource inefficient. Oh, interesting. I was wondering because I remember when Meteor.js came out, I did try the demo. I think we talked about it on the show years ago and it looked magical. Like it looked like, okay, well, you know, I have this slice of user data and I just want it to exist over here.
需要推送实时数据，但这在资源上的效率极其低下。哦，很有意思。我在想，因为我记得当 Meteor.js 刚出来的时候，我确实试过它的演示。我想我们几年前在节目中讨论过它，它看起来非常神奇。就像是，好的，你知道，我有这一片用户数据，我只想让它在这里存在。
And it just magically worked, but then it never took off. And it sounds maybe like this is why, like it just, it just at scale, it just fell apart. It was, it was, it was magical. It was truly magical. It was just, as soon as that group started to move to include other databases, they realized how incredibly challenging that was because they integrated it so closely. And so they ended up building an entire library that moved away from Meteor.js and ultimately became Prisma. That's what it was, Prisma.io. Oh yeah. I've heard of that too. Yep. Yeah. So that was the next iteration of that. That was the next iteration of how do we sync data between a client and a
它就像变魔术一样管用，但后来它却从未真正流行起来。听起来也许这就是原因，它在规模化时就崩溃了。它曾经真的非常神奇。确实太神奇了。只是，一旦那个团队开始扩展并支持其他数据库，他们就意识到这是多么具有挑战性，因为他们集成得太紧密了。因此，他们最终构建了一个完全脱离 Meteor.js 的库，并最终演变成了 Prisma。就是那个，Prisma.io。哦，对。我也听说过。是的。没错，这就是它的下一个迭代版本。那是关于如何在客户端和
server and do that in a more efficient way and not necessarily overwhelm with individual subscriptions. And they're all great use cases and they are truly magical for users, but they become incredibly resource intensive. So we are focusing on, I'd say less the long tail of simplicity and providing the bulk of functionality we can within what we know to be the limits of data replication between every single client on earth and one central data store. Because obviously the other challenge is if I give you access to every single piece of data,
服务器之间更高效地同步数据，而不必被单个订阅压垮的下一个迭代版本。这些都是很好的用例，对用户来说也确实很神奇，但它们变得极其消耗资源。因此，我们关注的重点，可以说较少追求简化的长尾，而是在我们已知的地球上每个客户端与一个中央数据存储之间的数据复制限制内，提供尽可能多的功能。因为显然另一个挑战是，如果我让你访问每一个数据，
then you could update that data. And now I have a billion clients that are all trying to resolve, you know, who did what, when, what was your network timestamp? You know, who came first? What's the right answer? And then you'll never get into financial services, which as you know, is where all the money is. Yeah, that's right. Closer to the money supply. Yeah. So it sounds like the Harper, sort of a center of mass for HarperDB is just using Netflix as an example. Netflix wants to push its most popular videos to the edge so that you don't have to go all the way to Los Gatos or wherever Netflix's data center is to get that video, right? And so you can imagine all over the world, there's a ton of these like small data centers hosting whatever the most popular Netflix
那你就可以更新这些数据。现在我有一亿个客户端都在试图解决，你知道的，谁在什么时候做了什么，你的网络时间戳是什么？你知道，谁先来的？什么是正确答案？然后你就永远无法涉足金融服务，正如你所知，所有的钱都在那里。是的，没错。离资金供应更近。是的。所以听起来 Harper，或者说 HarperDB 的核心，以 Netflix 为例。Netflix 想要将它最受欢迎的视频推送到边缘，这样你就不必大老远跑到洛斯加托斯（Los Gatos）或者 Netflix 的任何数据中心去获取那个视频了，对吧？所以你可以想象，在世界各地，有大量这样的小型数据中心托管着任何最受欢迎的 Netflix
video is. And so you have this cache and so people will go to the server. The server will say, oh, yep, I have that video. It's one of these super popular videos for your region. Here it is. Or, oh, I don't have this really esoteric video about leopards or something. I'm going to have to go to the main data center and go fetch that. But any time you write any kind of logic or really do anything with computer with a computer, you're going to want to keep some records. Right. You're going to want to keep track of how many people watched each video. And so now you could every time someone goes to watch a video, you could phone home to the main server. But now you hit a whole bunch of other issues, as we talked about with that main server now getting bombarded with tons of requests all the time, and it doesn't scale. So what HarperDB could do is sit on these edge nodes, collect all of those statistics,
视频。所以你有一个缓存，人们就会去访问服务器。服务器会说，哦，对，我有那个视频。这是针对你所在地区的超级热门视频之一。给你。或者，哦，我没有关于豹子什么的这种非常冷门的视频。我得去主数据中心把它取回来。但是，只要你编写任何逻辑，或者真正用计算机做任何事情，你都会想要保存一些记录。对吧。你会想要记录有多少人观看了每个视频。所以现在每次有人观看视频时，你都可以致电主服务器。但正如我们所讨论的那样，现在你会遇到一大堆其他问题，主服务器现在被大量的请求轰炸，而且它无法扩展。因此，HarperDB 可以做的是驻留在这些边缘节点上，收集所有这些统计数据，
so that tomorrow Netflix knows what videos are the most popular tomorrow and it can keep that fresh. And then all of that gets replicated as all these machines are ticking up this histogram of videos. And then at some point, maybe at the end of the day, someone or some process at Netflix can get a copy of this database that all these agitators are sharing and read it and learn some intelligence from it. Did I explain a use case pretty well or is there any? You did. And I'd go one step further to say, you would run an AI machine learning model to actively compress all of the individual data points that maybe come through a Netflix UI, a user experience. I might hover over a movie. I might watch the trailer for
这样明天的 Netflix 就能知道明天哪些视频最受欢迎，并且可以保持数据的更新。然后，随着所有这些机器不断累积这些视频的直方图，所有这些数据都会被复制。然后到某个时候，也许在一天结束时，Netflix 的某个人或某个进程可以获取所有这些聚合器正在共享的这个数据库的副本，并对其进行读取，从中获取一些智能信息。我把这个用例解释得够好了吗？还是有什么？你解释得很好。我还要更进一步地说，你可以运行一个人工智能机器学习模型，来主动压缩可能通过 Netflix UI（用户体验）传入的所有单个数据点。我可能会将鼠标悬停在一部电影上。我可能会观看它的
it. I might only get halfway through the trailer. If you've ever thumbed through your Netflix queue, gone past a row of films and gone back up, you'll see cover art change for films as they try to test different cover art to see if you'll click on that. So a lot of these decisions are simply like, we want to try A, B test this thing automatically. But at some point, somebody is going to realize that there's an advantage to one of those covers versus the other cover, at which point that is going to realize that there's an advantage to one of those covers versus the other cover, at which point that is going to become a policy that is rolled down to every single client. We're saying, this is the best cover for this. This is what gets people to click on this. Or based on this profile, we're going to show this cover and the demographic data
预告片。我可能只看了一半的预告片。如果你曾在 Netflix 的队列中翻找过，略过一排电影又返回去，你会发现电影的封面图会发生变化，因为他们试图测试不同的封面图，看看你是否会点击它。所以很多这样的决定很简单，比如：我们想自动进行 A/B 测试。但在某个时候，总会有人意识到其中一张封面相对于另一张封面有优势，此时，这将成为一项推送到每一个客户端的策略。我们说，这是这个的最佳封面。这就是能吸引人们点击它的东西。或者根据这个我们分类的用户画像和人口统计数据，
that we've classified. And we're going to run a machine learning model that will basically classify all of our users into one of three archetypes and the cover art is defined by that archetype all of that happens at the edge none of that you know aside from larger you know aggregation or probably strategies for that knowledge is going to happen at the edge. It'll happen in the cloud. But most of it you want to have happen out there. Otherwise, you run into the same problem everybody runs into before distributed computing was even a thing,
我们将展示这个封面。我们将运行一个机器学习模型，基本上将我们所有的用户归类为三种原型之一，而封面图就是由该原型决定的，这一切都发生在边缘。除了更大规模的聚合或可能针对该知识的策略之外，所有这些都不会发生在边缘。它会发生在云端。但大部分内容你都希望在外面发生。否则，你就会遇到分布式计算甚至还没出现时每个人都会遇到的问题，
which is, my God, we need this server to be literally the size of the planet. Right. Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. I think, too, there is this study. I'm sure you're more familiar with this, Ian, but there is there was some study that I think Google did this study back in like 2011, said, basically, for every millisecond it takes their site to load, their product gets hit in some significant way, or maybe it was every 10 milliseconds. And so there's the real economic advantages. It's one of these things that's probably innate or it's probably subconscious. You're not sitting there looking at your watch saying, oh, this was 80 milliseconds. I'm out. But subconsciously, the product gets hit hard every 10 milliseconds it takes to return a result.
那就是，天哪，我们需要这个服务器大得和地球一样。对。嗯。嗯，这说得通。我也觉得，有一个研究。伊恩，我相信你对此更熟悉，但有一个研究，我想谷歌在 2011 年左右做过这个研究，基本上说，他们的网站加载每延迟一毫秒，他们的产品就会受到某种程度的重大打击，或者也许是每 10 毫秒。所以这其中存在着真正的经济优势。这是那种可能是天生的或是潜意识的事情。你不会坐在那里看着手表说，哦，这花了 80 毫秒。我走了。但从潜意识里讲，返回结果每多花 10 毫秒，产品就会受到重创。
And so anything you can push to the edge just will turn into material dollars and cents. Exactly. And I mean, ultimately, we say that at least in gaming and in computing that 16 milliseconds is what the human being can perceive as a delay. So you want it to be down at 16 milliseconds. And I mentioned a case study earlier where users in Buenos Aires were spending, you know, a few milliseconds connecting to a local API, but then data would take anywhere between 300 milliseconds and 11 seconds to bring back a friends list.
所以你能推送到边缘的任何东西，都会转化为切实的真金白银。没错。我的意思是，归根结底，我们在游戏和计算领域常说，16 毫秒是人类能够感知到的延迟。所以你希望它降到 16 毫秒。我之前提到过一个案例研究，布宜诺斯艾利斯的 用户花了几毫秒连接本地 API，但随后拉取好友列表的数据需要 300 毫秒到 11 秒不等。
And when we started running our tests with our custom functions and the data, which had been replicated out, your friends list doesn't change all that often, but we'd replicated the data out right to where the endpoint was. And you were seeing response times of five to 10 milliseconds, which, you know, I, we knew that under load, we would see that push,
当我们开始使用自定义函数和已经复制出去的数据运行测试时，你的好友列表并不经常改变，但我们将数据直接复制到了端点所在的位置。你看到响应时间是 5 到 10 毫秒，你知道的，我们知道在负载下我们会看到这种推送，
but our objective was under a hundred milliseconds and we, and we beat that easily, which you were never, ever going to do if all of the data still lived in Seattle. Yep. Yep. Totally makes sense. Cool. Yeah. I think we covered a ton of really good material here. I think we opened all the bookmarks, which is good. Let's jump into HarperDB as a company. So what's something that is kind of unique about HarperDB? It could be the way you play in your off sites. It could be the layout of the office. Or what's something where when you showed up at Harper or maybe through your tenure there, it's really made
但我们的目标是 100 毫秒以内，而我们轻松做到了这一点，如果所有数据仍然保存在西雅图，你是绝对、绝对做不到这一点的。对。对。完全说得通。太好了。是的，我觉得我们在这里讨论了大量非常棒的内容。我觉得我们打开了所有的书签，这很好。让我们来聊聊 HarperDB 这家公司。那么 HarperDB 有什么独特之处呢？可能是你们远程办公时玩耍的方式，可能是办公室的布局。或者当你在 Harper 入职时，或者在你在那里的任职期间，有什么真正让
Harper stand out in terms of the work environment? Well, I think if you go to the site, you'll see our logo is a dog. Harper's actually our CEO's dog's name. Oh, wow. Okay. All of our demo datasets, if you go to our postman collection, if you go to docs.harperdb.io, you'll see we have a ton of demos and our demo data sets are all the dogs owned by the people in the office and then a breeds table. So you can do a join of those data sets. So all of our demos are based on the concepts of dogs. And at the end of the day, it's about somebody who is hopelessly loyal to you, always there. And ultimately, they make your life better. And so if that is the driving
Harper 在工作环境中脱颖而出？嗯，我想如果你去我们的网站，你会看到我们的标志是一只狗。Harper 实际上是我们 CEO 的狗的名字。哦，哇。好的。我们所有的演示数据集，如果你去看我们的 Postman 集合，如果你去 docs.harperdb.io，你会发现我们有很多演示，而我们的演示数据集都是办公室里的人养的狗，还有一个品种（breeds）表。所以你可以对这些数据集进行连接（join）。因此，我们所有的演示都是基于狗的概念。归根结底，这是关于一个对你无比忠诚、随时陪伴在你身边、最终让你的生活变得更好的人。所以如果那是
architecture of every employee we hire, every feature we look at on our feature up board and say, do enough people want this? Is it going to make people's lives better? And a lot of us are multidisciplinary software guys. So we've seen lots of problems over time. And to be honest, this product was built to solve problems that the founders were having in specific application at their former company. But they solve a lot of problems that I've had too. And there's no limit to problems you face as a programmer. And we call our approach ultimately collapsing the stack. So we have now effectively Lambda functions or old school, you might call them stored procedures, but they're written in JavaScript and they're super easy to deploy and they
我们雇用的每一位员工、我们在功能板上查看的每一个功能并讨论“是否有足够多的人想要这个？它会让人们的生活变得更好吗？”的驱动架构。而且我们中的许多人都是多学科的软件工程师。所以随着时间的推移，我们见过很多问题。说实话，这个产品就是为了解决创始人在他们以前公司的特定应用程序中遇到的问题而构建的。但它们也解决了我遇到过的很多问题。作为程序员，你面临的问题是无限的。我们最终将我们的方法称为折叠技术栈（collapsing the stack）。所以我们现在有效地拥有了 Lambda 函数，或者老派一点，你可能会称它们为存储过程，但它们是用 JavaScript 编写的，超级容易部署，它们
make your life easier and better. And hopefully you can spend less time working on that and more time outside playing with your dog, which is all they really want. Yeah. Do you let dogs in the office? This is a great debate. I've worked at places where dogs are in the office. I never had an issue with it. Definitely some people didn't like it. And I've worked at places where dogs were banned and people really didn't like that either. What's Harper's take on dogs at the office? Well, when we had an office-
让你的生活更轻松、更好。希望你能花更少的时间处理这些，而有更多的时间去外面和你的狗玩耍，这其实才是它们真正想要的。是的。你们允许狗进办公室吗？这是一个很好的争论。我工作过的地方有允许狗进办公室的。我从来没觉得有什么问题。当然也有一些人不喜欢。我也工作过地方是禁止带狗的，人们其实也很讨厌那样。Harper 对办公室带狗有什么看法？嗯，当我们有办公室的时候——
Oh, that's true too. When we had an office, dogs were absolutely welcome. The irony is that Harper was not a nice dog and Harper was the only dog. If Harper wanted to come to the office, no other dogs can come in the office. But otherwise you could like, there was, we had, we talked about conflict, uh, resolution, replicated data types. Um, ultimately there were also conflict resolution dog types where certain mixes of dogs were allowed in, but if that dog was going to come, we definitely knew you can't bring this dog because they will not get along. Yeah, you need operational transforms for dogs. This person has to get transformed across the hallway or something.
哦，这也是个问题。当我们有办公室时，狗是绝对受欢迎的。具有讽刺意味的是，Harper 不是一只好狗，而且 Harper 是唯一的一只狗。如果 Harper 想来办公室，其他任何狗都不能进办公室。否则你可以，我们曾讨论过冲突解决、复制数据类型。最终，其实也有冲突解决狗狗类型，特定品种组合的狗是被允许进来的，但如果那只狗要来，我们肯定知道你不能带这只狗，因为它们合不来。是的，你们需要针对狗的操作转换（operational transforms）。这个人必须被转换到走廊对面什么的。
The SQL query we're not in. Yeah, that's right. Where dog's not in disagrees with this dog. I think in the last episode, we were talking with the CEO of Pinecode, which is a database that does vector arithmetic database. And Patrick was bringing up R trees. I think this would be a perfect example where we could have rectangles for each zone of influence for each dog. And if we get an overlap, that throws an alert or something. Yes.
我们没参与的 SQL 查询。是的，没错。狗不在其中的地方不同意这只狗。我想在上一集里，我们采访了 Pinecode 的 CEO，这是一家做向量算术数据库的公司。帕特里克（Patrick）提到了 R 树（R-trees）。我认为这将是一个完美的例子，我们可以为每只狗的影响范围画出矩形。如果我们遇到重叠，就会触发警报什么的。是的。
The Venn diagram of dogs that don't get along is just a circle. Yes. The, the, the Venn diagram of dogs that don't get along. It's just a circle. You cannot, it's just, we can't put all these dogs in one room. It's just too many dogs. So, so, okay. So it's distributed. So, you know, are you hiring sort of interns or full timers and where are you hiring? What kind of people are you hiring? You kind of walk us through, you know, people could definitely, I'm sure you have a careers page and people can check it out, but just ostensibly at a high level, what are, what are you looking, you know, for HarperDB on the engineering side? What kind of persona are you, are you looking for? We just went through a, we just had our first hiring round in a couple of years.
合不来的狗的韦恩图（Venn diagram）只是一个圆。是的，合不来的狗的韦恩图。它只是一个圆。你不能，就是我们不能把所有这些狗放在同一个房间里。狗实在太多了。所以，好吧。所以它是分布式的。那么，你们是在招聘实习生还是全职员工？你们在哪些地方招聘？你们都在招什么样的人？你能给我们介绍一下吗，人们肯定，我确信你们有一个招聘页面，人们可以去查看，但表面上从宏观层面来看，在工程方面，你们在寻找什么样的人？你们在寻找什么样的画像？我们刚刚经历了一轮招聘。我们刚刚进行了几年来的第一轮招聘。
We built out all of our core functionality and now we're ready to, I think we got what I'd call the first versions of this where we're figuring out what is the thing supposed to do? How is it supposed to work? And what is our technical debt left over from that learning process? And we've cleaned that up. And so now we're out there looking for a new full stack developer. And we were looking for a designer and then an infrastructure developer, because we're finding that the bulk of the challenge, once the product is sound, we want to increase the size of the team that's helping build cool new features. But right now our features make it super easy to deploy and we think it meets the needs of most of our customers. Now it becomes the services layer that we put in place to help big customers solve their architecture problems
我们构建了所有的核心功能，现在我们准备好，我想我们已经达到了我所说的第一版本，我们正在弄清楚这个东西应该做什么？它应该如何工作？我们在学习过程中遗留的技术债务是什么？我们已经清理干净了。所以现在我们在寻找一名新的全栈开发人员。我们还在寻找一名设计师和一名基础设施开发人员，因为我们发现，一旦产品稳定，最大的挑战就是我们希望扩大团队规模，以帮助构建很酷的新功能。但目前我们的功能使得部署变得超级简单，我们认为它满足了大多数客户的需求。现在它变成了我们为帮助大客户解决架构问题而建立的服务层，
because distributed computing is a new paradigm for many of them. So an infrastructure developer, somebody familiar with taking a Kubernetes cluster and extending it across public private clouds, figuring out how to make it work with edge devices and script all of the intranode connectivity. So we're looking for obviously very smart people in DevOps, a full stack software engineer. Node.js is what we're written in. So Node.js is a prerequisite there. We are also not solving, I wouldn't call them traditional programming problems. We're in a very, very specific space. So we're not looking for extremely experienced programmers. We're looking for people who sort of get it and understand the goal is to build something that's a joy to use. And as such, there might be a little more heavy lifting on our side so that there's a little less heavy lifting,
因为分布式计算对他们许多人来说是一个新的范式。因此，基础设施开发人员需要熟悉如何获取 Kubernetes 集群并将其扩展到公有云和私有云之间，弄清楚如何让它与边缘设备配合工作，并编写所有节点间连接的脚本。所以我们显然在寻找 DevOps 领域非常聪明的人，以及一名全栈软件工程师。我们是用 Node.js 编写的。所以 Node.js 是一个先决条件。我们也没有在解决，我不会称它们为传统的编程问题。我们在一个非常非常具体的领域。所以我们并不是在寻找经验极其丰富的程序员。我们在寻找那些能够理解并明白目标是构建一个使用起来令人愉快的东西的人。因此，我们这边可能需要承担更多重活，
you know, on the parts of developers who are using our product. So to that end, we really, really like to be able to take somebody in and make sure that they care what the customer thinks. Because there's a lot of developers who want a functional spec and they want to build out according to code. And then they want to check out. And I met the objective and I'm like, guess what? The objectives are going to change every day, but there's one core and that's it'll only change
这样使用我们产品的开发人员就能少承担一些重活。为此，我们真的非常非常喜欢能够招入一个人，并确保他们关心客户的想法。因为有很多开发人员想要一份功能规范，然后他们想要根据代码进行构建。然后他们就签退了。我达到了目标，而我想说的是：猜怎么着？目标每天都会变，但有一个核心永远不会变，
if it makes it easier to use, more stable, smaller, tighter, faster, whatever. And the other part is you're free to bring suggestions to the table just as much as our CTO or myself or our director of marketing who's out there on dev too, uh, you know, and reading all the articles and all the feedback on our blog posts. And it's like, you know what? Everybody hates this thing. Yep. Like they talk about how we don't solve it, but nobody solves it and everybody hates it. And maybe we should look at
那就是：只有当它变得更易用、更稳定、更小、更紧凑、更快等等时，它才会变。另一个部分是，你可以自由地提出建议，就像我们的 CTO、我自己，或是我们的市场总监一样，他在 Dev.to 上发表文章，阅读我们博客文章的所有评论和反馈，然后说：你知道吗？所有人都在讨厌这个东西。是的。就像他们讨论我们是如何没有解决这个问题，但没有人解决这个问题，每个人都讨厌它。也许我们应该看看
that. And that's just as valid as an idea, um, as the idea that, you know, our clustering engine should perhaps change to something written in a lower level language so that it's faster. Yeah, totally makes sense. Yeah. So, so the job isn't just, uh, you know just inverting the binary tree or solving some really tricky dynamic programming problem or something like that. That's not actually the job. That might be something you have to learn as a rite of passage, but it's not the job. Yeah, I mean, you'll totally do those things. You'll totally 100% do that. But we've got so much of the core written that at this point, our patented data model and our indexing and all the things we do are really, really solid. I think we'd love somebody to become familiar enough with it that our CTO could take a day off. That'd be nice every once in a while, right?
这个。这同样是一个很好的想法，就像我们的集群引擎应该改变为用更底层语言编写以使其更快这样的想法一样。完全说得通。是的。所以，这项工作不仅仅是，你知道的，反转二叉树或者解决一些非常棘手的动态规划问题之类的。这其实并不是这项工作。那可能是你作为成人礼必须学习的东西，但那不是这项工作。是的，我的意思是，你完全会做这些事情。你完全 100% 会做那些。但我们的核心已经编写了很大一部分，在这一点上，我们获得专利的数据模型、索引以及我们所做的一切都真的非常非常坚固。我想我们很乐意让某人对它足够熟悉，以至于我们的 CTO 可以请一天假。偶尔那样不是很棒吗，对吧？
But I think the other, the other part is just the flexibility to say, I don't know the answer, but also nobody knows the answer. So let's figure out a way to write it two or three or 10 times, test it all and figure out what the right answer is right now. One of the things I realized that the most authoritative paper on resolving conflicts in distributed computing was written in 1984 by a woman at Microsoft. That's the paper that all of the articles eventually go back to her site as the primary influence. And we've known it was a problem for a very long time.
但我认为另一部分，只是拥有这样一种灵活性：我不知道答案，但也没有人知道答案。所以让我们想办法写两遍、三遍或十遍，测试所有这些，并找出此刻正确的答案。我意识到的一件事是，关于解决分布式计算中冲突的最具权威性的论文是 1984 年由微软的一位女性撰写的。那篇论文是所有文章最终都会追溯到她的网站作为主要影响来源的论文。而且我们知道这是一个问题已经很长时间了。
And we still have and people still end up with that article because we have not solved that problem yet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if that is the same as Paxos. I've heard the name Paxos a lot. I think that's some way to do, I think, leader election and solve conflicts. That paper, at least in my circle, seems to come up a lot. But what everyone tells me, and I'm sure you've seen this too, is it's great in theory. Everything's great in theory. And then in practice, you have to find out the right corners to cut
我们仍然有，人们最终还是会回到那篇论文，因为我们还没有解决那个问题。是的。是的。我不知道这是否和 Paxos 是一回事。我经常听到 Paxos 这个名字。我认为这是某种做到这一点的方法，我认为是领导者选举和解决冲突。那篇论文，至少在我的圈子里，似乎经常被提起。但每个人都告诉我，我相信你也见过，它在理论上很棒。一切在理论上都很棒。然后在实践中，你必须找出需要做出妥协的正确角落，
so that something doesn't take three months to be consistent. And also, on the flip side, doesn't have massive errors. And so it's playing that game, I think, is a question of what do the customers really value? I think at the end of the day is what really matters. I think somewhere down the line, the idea of RAF consensus, election, all of that will, will fade away. And the data itself will contain bits of metadata that allow you to have a leaderless distributed system. So inherently all of the information you need to know about what you need to do is present for each node to,
这样某些事情就不会花三个月时间才能达到一致。而且在另一方面，也不会产生巨大的错误。所以玩这个游戏，我认为是一个关于客户真正重视什么的问题。我认为归根结底，这才是真正重要的。我认为在未来的某个时候，Raft 共识、选举等所有这些概念都会逐渐消退，数据本身将包含元数据位，使你能够拥有一个无主（leaderless）的分布式系统。因此，本质上，你需要了解你需要做什么的所有信息都存在于每个节点中，
to execute rather than having a central broker that kind of directs traffic because you could have a cluster or two leaders or failover or whatever, but inevitably it's going to be a single point of failure if you wait for that one person to make that decision. You're going to have lots of people doing things and it won't scale. So it is my thought that ultimately it will be able to decide in a deterministic manner by itself, just based on the data itself. And it has some interesting applications down the road
供其执行，而不是有一个中央代理来某种程度上指挥流量，因为你可能有一个集群或两个领导者、故障转移等等，但不可避免地，如果你等待那个人做出决定，它将成为一个单点故障。你会遇到很多人在做事情，而且它无法扩展。所以我的想法是，最终它将能够以确定性的方式自行决定，仅仅基于数据本身。它在未来有一些有趣的应用，
for quantum computing where, you know, you can make probabilistic determinations across massive data sets. And obviously databases are supposed to be deterministic. And there's a lot of debate about whether or not quantum computing could ever be used for data persistence or data logic. But I think there's a tremendous opportunity there to find the lowest energy solution or the probable lowest energy solutions for a query. It just requires a lot more qubits than we have right now. But 10 years down the line, man, my patent is going to be awesome. Yeah. And to the point you brought up earlier, I mean, there is a double spend problem and there are like very specific niche cases where you do have to spend that time and you do have to have sort of that
比如量子计算，你可以在海量数据集上做出概率判定。很明显，数据库应该是确定性的。关于量子计算是否可以用于数据持久化或数据逻辑，有很多争论。但我认为这里有一个巨大的机会，可以为查询找到最低能量解或可能的最低能量解。它只是需要比我们现在拥有的更多的量子比特（qubits）。但十年后，天哪，我的专利将是惊人的。是的。正如你之前提出的观点，我的意思是，存在双花问题，并且有一些非常具体的细分案例，你确实需要花时间去解决，也确实需要那种
perfect answer. But the vast, vast majority of the time, you don't. And so in all of these instances, you can use edge computing, you can use things like HarperDB and all these like edge computing services that kind of make it easy to deploy to the edge. Docker, all the things we talked about will be extremely, extremely important. And then that one time when you actually click the checkout button, that time, you know, it can go to the server and take a long time. And people kind of expect that. They expect, OK, if my credit card is go to the server and take a long time. And people kind of expect that they expect, okay, if my credit card is going to get charged, I expect to wait a little bit. And you can kind of have the best of both worlds just by being smart and about when do I use A or B and, and, and both of them are extremely, extremely important.
完美的答案。但绝大多数、绝大多数时候，你并不需要。所以在所有这些实例中，你可以使用边缘计算，你可以使用像 HarperDB 这样的服务，以及所有这些使部署到边缘变得容易的边缘计算服务。Docker，我们谈论的所有事情都将极其极其重要。然后当你实际点击结账按钮的那一次，那一次，你知道的，它可以去访问服务器并花费很长时间。人们对此也有所期待。他们期待，好吧，如果我的信用卡要被扣款，我愿意等一会儿。通过明智地选择何时使用 A 或 B，你可以两全其美，并且这两者都极其极其重要。
Exactly. It's the, it's the challenge that you want. You want it to be as fast as possible, but not too fast. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. Yeah. Now a fast as possible without hubris, right? Exactly. That is, that is, that is the Sisyphean struggle, right? Yeah. We push, we push the rock up the hill every day. Yeah. Very cool. Cool. So let's jump into how people can reach, um, you know, you and how people can learn more about HarperDB. And what are some good resources for folks out there? And alongside that, we have a lot of folks who are in university who love can try out HarperDB for free? Is there a permanent free tier? Or what are some of the opportunities for them? It'd be great to kind of cover some of those bases. Sure.
没错。这就是你想要的挑战。你希望它尽可能快，但又不能太快。是的，没错。是的。现在，要做到没有傲慢的尽可能快，对吧？没错，那就是，那就是西西弗斯的挣扎，对吧？是的，我们每天都在把巨石推上山。非常酷。太棒了。让我们来谈谈人们如何联系你，以及人们如何了解更多关于 HarperDB 的信息。对于那里的朋友们，有哪些好的资源？除此之外，我们有很多身处大学的朋友，他们很喜欢可以免费试用 HarperDB 吗？有没有永久免费层？或者有哪些适合他们的机会？涵盖其中一些基础知识会很棒。当然。
Our URL is harperdb.io. On there, we have a docs tab, which will teach you everything you need to know from getting started. You can install HarperDB locally. It just requires Node.js and NPM. You can just NPM IG HarperDB. Super easy. We also have a management studio, which is web-based. Even your local instances, because obviously your browser is capable of making local network connections. You can manage local and cloud and other instances that you might have installed through RStudio. That allows you to connect instances to each other, set up intra-node data replication at a table level, pub and sub,
我们的网址是 harperdb.io。上面有一个文档（docs）标签页，它会教给你从入门开始需要了解的一切。你可以在本地安装 HarperDB。它只需要 Node.js 和 NPM。你只需运行 `NPM i -g harperdb`。超级简单。我们还有一个基于网页的管理工作室（Management Studio）。甚至你的本地实例也可以，因为显然你的浏览器能够建立本地网络连接。你可以通过我们的 Studio 管理本地、云端以及你可能安装的其他实例。这允许你将实例相互连接，在表级别设置节点间数据复制，发布和订阅（pub and sub），
as well as our new custom functions feature where you can hang your lambdas basically off the side of HarperDB at its own API endpoint. So you can not just use our operations API, but set up something with third-party authentication that makes a query, perhaps inserts some data, then runs another query, calculates an average, and inserts it into a time series table. It's a super cool piece of functionality that then you can package up a project, click a button and send it to any of the other HarperDB instances in your organization. So it's very easy to deploy these as well. That system is backed by our own AWS hosted collection of Lambdas. And obviously, if you've worked with Lambdas before,
以及我们新的自定义函数（custom functions）功能，你可以在 HarperDB 旁边挂载你的 Lambda 函数，拥有它自己的 API 端点。因此，你不仅可以使用我们的操作 API，还可以通过第三方身份验证设置某些东西，进行查询，也许插入一些数据，然后运行另一个查询，计算平均值，并将其插入到时间序列表中。这是一个超级酷的功能，然后你可以打包一个项目，点击一个按钮，将其发送到你组织中的任何其他 HarperDB 实例。所以部署这些也非常容易。该系统由我们自己的托管在 AWS 上的 Lambda 集合提供支持。显然，如果你以前用过 Lambda，
you know that deploying them and writing them and getting them out everywhere is not necessarily always the easiest. So we took a note on that and we tried to make it easier. We think we accomplished it. We do have, within our studio, the ability to spin up a HarborDB Cloud instance, which is our database-as-a-service product,
你就会知道部署它们、编写它们并将它们分发到各处并不总是最容易的。所以我们注意到了这一点，并试图让它变得更简单。我们认为我们做到了。我们在 Studio 中确实具备启动 HarperDB Cloud 实例的功能，这是我们的数据库即服务产品，
which is your own EC2 node with HarborDB running on it. We have a free tier. There's also a free tier for the locally installed instances. And you can effectively network all of these things together, watch the data move around a system, run your local instance on a Raspberry Pi, collect some sensor data, watch that get replicated up. It's really, really easy to set up a very, you know, a comprehensive distributed computing application in only a few minutes using HarperDB and the studio.
它是在其上运行 HarperDB 的你自己的 EC2 节点。我们有一个免费层。本地安装的实例也有一个免费层。你可以有效地将所有这些东西联网在一起，观察数据在系统中的流动，在树莓派（Raspberry Pi）上运行你的本地实例，收集一些传感器数据，看着它被向上复制。使用 HarperDB 和 Studio，只需几分钟就可以非常轻松地建立一个全面且分布式的计算应用程序。
That's super, super cool. So folks at home, you can, most people have a Raspberry Pi. We've been telling people to buy Raspberry Pis for what, half a decade or something. So you have a Raspberry Pi, you have a computer, you can run HarperDB on the Pi, run HarperDB on the computer. And then whenever you, you know, insert foo into table bar, it just shows up on the computer, which is pretty cool. I mean, there's a lot of really fun stuff you can do with that. If you want to have a Raspberry Pi, we're working on a Raspberry Pi
这真是酷毙了。所以家里的朋友们，你可以，大多数人都有一个树莓派。我们告诉人们买树莓派已经有五年左右了吧。所以你有一个树莓派，你有一台电脑，你可以在树莓派上运行 HarperDB，在电脑上运行 HarperDB。然后每当你，你知道的，把 foo 插入到表 bar 中时，它就会显示在电脑上，这真的很酷。我的意思是，你可以用它做很多非常有趣的事情。如果你想拥有一个树莓派，我们正在制作一个树莓派
water fountain to control a water pump. That's the latest project the family's been doing. And so we could just have a database, which is just saying, when should I turn on the water fountain or should I have it on right now? And then from our computer, we could just, you know, change, change a value in that database and boom, the water fountain shuts off. So, so there's a whole bunch of really fun stuff you can do with this. And then as you learn that technology and you go to a company that, you know, is moving a lot of bits and needs to do things at the edge for all the reasons we talked about, you'll have that experience. You'll be ready to go and you'll have sort of a leg up there. Absolutely. I wrote a thermostat program for my own house. I have old fan coil units that either have hot air going
喷泉来控制水泵。这是家里人一直在做的最新项目。所以我们可以只有一个数据库，它只是在说：我什么时候应该打开喷泉，或者我现在应该把它打开吗？然后从我们的电脑上，我们可以，你知道的，更改该数据库中的一个值，轰的一声，喷泉就关掉了。所以，你可以用这个做一大堆非常有趣的事情。然后，当你学习了这项技术，并去了一家，你知道的，正在移动大量比特并且出于我们讨论过的所有原因需要在边缘做事情的公司时，你就会拥有那种经验。你将准备就绪，并且在那里占据一定的优势。绝对的。我为我自己的房子编写了一个恒温器程序。我有旧的风机盘管机组，它们要么有热空气流过，
through or hot water going through them or cold water going through them. And depending on that, based on the temperature, if you want it colder, you need to know what the temperature of the water is because you don't want it to just turn on. So you need this piece of data. And I wrote it on a Raspberry Pi with a little seven inch monitor on top of it. And it runs HarperDB that stores it. And it does a little predictive temperature curve. It does third-party calls to the weather service. It will turn on the cooling if there's cold water in there and it knows it's going to be hot later. It may turn on the air conditioning a little early. So it's a super easy and simple system
要么有热水流过，要么有冷水流过。根据这些，基于温度，如果你想让它更冷，你需要知道水的温度，因为你不想让它直接启动。所以你需要这部分数据。我把它写在一个树莓派上，上面带有一个小七英寸显示器。它运行存储数据的 HarperDB。它会做一个小的预测性温度曲线。它会对天气服务进行第三方调用。如果有冷水进来了，它会开启制冷，并且它知道待会儿会变热。它可能会稍微提前一点打开空调。所以这是一个超级简单直接的系统，
that then actuates the power button on any given fan coil unit in the house based on which window is that facing and does that room face? And is it time for it to be colder in here now? Or can I wait until later in the afternoon? It's a very, very simple proof of concept, but it's one that, you know, a commercial thermostat was never going to meet my needs. Yeah. Wow, that's super cool.
然后根据房子里的窗户朝向和房间朝向，来启动家中任何给定风机盘管机组上的电源按钮。现在是时候让这里变得更凉爽了吗？还是我可以等到下午晚些时候？这是一个非常非常简单的概念验证，但它是一个，你知道的，商用恒温器永远无法满足我需求的方案。哇，太酷了。
And yeah, and this way they can all talk to each other and they can all be aware of each other. So if one of them is going, you know, all out, the other ones know that, okay, maybe the temperature is going to drop and they can kind of bootstrap off of each other. Exactly. Yeah. Very cool. I'm just trying to save $2.
是的，通过这种方式，它们都可以互相交流，并且都可以彼此了解。因此，如果其中一个正在全力运转，其他的就会知道，好吧，也许温度会下降，它们可以互相借鉴。没错。是的。太酷了。我只是想省 2 美元。
I just want to save $2. Yeah. That's the engineer thing, right? It's like, well, I could purchase this product for $99. I could purchase a Bugs snag subscription for 10 a month but i think i'll write my own and spend three years you know no we're right from scratch under the guise of someday i'll productize this and i'll get all that money back yeah that's right never never works never works cool uh jackson was so awesome having you on the
我只是想省 2 美元。是的。这就是工程师的思维，对吧？就像是，好吧，我可以花 99 美元购买这个产品。我可以买一个每月 10 美元的 Bugsnag 订阅，但我想我会自己写一个并花三年时间，你知道的，不，我们从头开始编写，借口是总有一天我会把这个产品化，然后我能把所有的钱都赚回来。是的，没错，从来没有用过，从来没有用过。酷。杰克逊，非常高兴你能来节目，
show um i learned a ton i know patrick and I have learned a ton about edge computing from you and I really appreciate it. Folks at home have learned a bunch. If you want to reach out to HarperDB, they're on Twitter. We'll post a link to on social media and show off what you've built. I think they'd love to see that. And I'll also post the site and everything else. Thank you so much for coming on the show. I really appreciate it. You're welcome. I had a great time. Cool.
我学到了很多，我知道帕特里克和我从你这里学到了很多关于边缘计算的知识，我真的很感激。家里的朋友们也学到了很多。如果你想联系 HarperDB，他们在推特上。我们会在社交媒体上发布一个链接，展示你构建的东西。我想他们会很乐意看到。我也会发布网站和其他所有东西。非常感谢你来节目。我真的很感激。不客气。我度过了一段美好的时光。酷。
And for everyone out there, thanks for subscribing to us on Patreon and checking out Audible on our behalf. We really appreciate that. And we will catch everyone in a couple of weeks. See you later. Music by Eric Barnwell. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于这里的每个人，感谢我们在 Patreon 上订阅我们并代表我们查看 Audible。我们对此表示非常感谢。我们会在几周内与大家见面。再见。音乐由 Eric Barnwell 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音、改编，但你必须注明对帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式分享。该集目前没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。